this course will help you find a
programming job and it's specifically
designed for self-taught developers Lane
Wagner has created some of our most
popular courses and he's back to teach
this course he covers everything from
job search strategy resumés networking
interviewing and a lot more let's start
learning look the job market for
entry-level developers is absolutely
brutal right now but that doesn't mean
there's no hope now I've personally
worked with hundreds of students that
are looking for their first programming
job and I'm absolutely shook by how
poorly so many students are representing
themselves as they look for jobs now
what that means for you is if you don't
make all of those super common mistakes
you'll actually stand out in what seems
like a c of other candidates so what
even is this course well it's a
collection of tactics and strategies
that I believe will help you maximize
your chances of Landing that first
programming job we'll start by making
sure that your resume GitHub LinkedIn
and personal projects are all up to
Snuff and optimized for actually Landing
that first developer job now if you
stick around all the way to the end of
the course I'll even talk you through
some of the most effective strategies
for applying networking and even nailing
technical interviews I guess I'll
introduce myself real quick I'm Lane
Wagner I'm the host of the back-end
Baner podcast I've been building
software for a little over 10 years and
I've actually worked as a hiring manager
for the last three now I don't just want
you hearing my opinions so I've actually
interviewed over 20 other industry
experts just to prepare for this course
you'll be hearing some of their stories
and advice directly from them later in
the video I've also been in touch with
Quincy lson himself yes the founder of
free code Camp which is of course the
YouTube channel that you're watching
this on right now he recently published
a wonderful free book called how to
learn to code and get a developer job so
we'll be covering some of that content
in this course as well the point is
you'll actually be hearing from some
pretty amazing people in in this video
and I kind of feel bad that you'll be
stuck with me for so much of it now this
course is actually quite a bit different
from the other coding courses that I've
published because we're not actually
going to be doing any coding in this
video but it's still going to be very
Hands-On all along the way you'll be
making updates to your resume tweaking
social profiles and even adding
documentation to projects there's going
to be a ton of stuff to do so please
don't just binge watch this video from
start to finish in fact I highly
recommend bookmarking the video and
taking it a step at a time now
everything that you need for this course
will be in this video but if you do want
a text version of the course to follow
along with that's available for free
over on boot. I'll be sure to drop a
direct link down in the description
below if you do want to follow along
that way and don't worry it's completely
free to make a boot dodev account and
all of the content for this course in
fact all of the content on boot. is free
a paid membership really just unlocks
some of the interactive features that
you won't need for this course and just
so you do know this course is part of a
full back-end developer career path over
on boot. dev so if you are interested in
going from zero to hirable as a backend
developer you can definitely check that
out as well now if you do get stuck at
any point during this course or want
some feedback there are a few resources
that you have available to you the first
is the boot dodev Discord community and
the second is the free code Camp Discord
and if you want to connect with me
directly you can follow me on Twitter at
Wags Lane you can also check out my
podcast
back in banter that's here on YouTube or
anywhere that you can listen to podcasts
now before we dive into the content I've
got one last thing to say in fact it's
really more of a disclaimer and that is
that a course about getting a job is
fundamentally very different from a
course on computer science look there is
a concrete correct answer to the
question how do I invert a binary trade
there's not a correct answer to how
should I build out my resume what does a
good template look like so I just want
you to go into this course knowing that
basically everything we're going to talk
about here is subjective all of the
advice you're going to hear is really
just my advice and the other guests
advice on what they think are the best
strategies for landing a job based on
their personal experiences so just take
everything we say with a giant grain of
salt now let's talk about how to get
your first job this first chapter of the
course is going to be all about overall
strategy right some general ideas that
if you can put them into place they'll
really help you over the long Long Haul
and remember we're kind of in this for
the Long Haul getting that first
programming job is quite difficult like
I'm not going to sugarcoat it for you
the first programming job is probably
the hardest programming job that you'll
ever land not in the sense that the job
itself is going to be all that hard but
that it's going to be the most difficult
job search your second job your third
job it really gets easier over time as
you gain more and more experience
because future employers will be able to
look at your past work experience as
sort of proof that you can do the job
okay it's story time let's draw little
graph along the x axis this will be
time and along the Y AIS this this will
be the
likelyhood of
getting a job that up out of the way
likelihood of getting a job okay I want
you to be able to have a goodlooking
graph every person's graph is going to
look different and let let me show you
what I mean let's start drawing and I'll
just use I'll just use some orange okay
when you just start learning to code the
likelihood of you getting a job is
extremely low so you're starting off
down in this bottom leand corner now as
you progress
learning this likelihood of getting a
job job should hopefully go up over time
right in fact let me label this we'll
say this is while you're kind of
still still
learning what can happen that's really
dangerous is you might complete some
sort of learning program so that could
be you get your CS degree it could be
you finish a boot camp it could be you
finish an online course or a large
project but sometimes what will happen
with people that I've
is you'll hit this wall where you kind
of think okay I'm basically done
learning now or maybe even to put it
more mildly I've learned enough that
it's time to get a job right and when
that happens because you stop
learning the likelihood of you getting a
job as time goes on if you stop learning
either stays stagnant let me go back to
Orange
stays stagnant like this right or in the
worst case scenario it actually goes
down over
time because every month that passes you
have a larger and larger gap on your
resume right if if your resume says I
completed my CS degree or I completed my
boot camp or my online course in
February and now it's September and you
have no work history in there like that
starts to get worse and worse for you so
I want to propose an
alternative and the alternative is once
you decide like once you hit this
threshold let's say there's this like
threshold where you feel like you've
learned enough let's just say it's right
there in fact I'll draw it over here on
the graph you hit this threshold of you
kind of learned enough that you should
start your job
search what you want to do is spend
roughly 50% of your time still learning
right and usually that means means
building projects it can also mean doing
online courses or tutorials um but
really building projects is probably the
best thing um and then the other 50% of
the time you should be spending on the
kinds of things that we're going to talk
about this course right actively going
and finding a job whether that's cold
applying or networking or whatever but
if you do that then as time goes on the
likelihood of you getting a job just
keeps going up and up because you're
making yourself a better developer with
every month that passes and I want to
tell you a little story about this I got
a traditional CS degree and when I was
still in school this would have been
about
2013 I met a guy who had graduated with
the same CS degree from the same
University 3 years earlier and he was
working as a janitor at the local
hospital now there's nothing wrong with
working as a a janitor but of course he
had a CS degree like he wanted to be
working as a programmer or as a software
engineer the problem was when he
graduated with his degree he didn't have
any portfolio projects He didn't have
any internships he didn't have any work
experience so he spent you know 3 to six
months looking for a job after
graduation wasn't able to find anything
in that period and kind of just gave up
he really experienced that first line
that I showed where you know when he
first graduated from University he may
have you know had had this kind of a
likelihood of getting a job way up here
but as time passed it actually got
harder and harder and harder and it
makes sense right if you graduate or
finish your program and two years down
the line you're still looking for work
but you haven't really done any projects
or any freelancing or any or just hadn't
had a job in those those two years it
kind of looks a little suspicious on
your resume like employers look at that
and they go well why hasn't anybody
hired this person in the last 2 years
maybe I shouldn't hire them either so
anyways this freaked me out quite a bit
right I'm looking at this guy who's
three years graduated from the degree
that I'm currently in I'm like am I in
the wrong field am I going to be able to
find a job when I graduate turns out I
really didn't have too much of a problem
I had to put in a ton of leg work you
know I probably put out 50 60 70
applications um when I graduated I I got
kind of a part time job in my senior
year and I built a ton of projects on
the side Capstone projects but really
you know my goal the whole time was just
to make sure that every month that
passed I'm becoming more and more and
more employable right so you don't get
this this kind of trough of Sorrow uh
after you complete your learning and as
we all know you never complete your
learning as a programmer like that's an
insane not o so I really want to get
this idea um of the threshold in your
mind not as a threshold for you to stop
learning and start doing your job search
but just as a threshold that you hit and
now you start your job search while
you're still learning and building so to
give you a rough idea of what you should
practically do um let's let's put it
like this let's split up your time into
learning and build
some of your time over here and then on
the other side we'll say applying and
networking really just anything any
activities that have to do with actually
you know doing the job
search for Learning and building where
before you were maybe spending 100% of
your available time learning and
building right so you you had of 100% of
your time here and you had add
0% of your time here like this makes
sense when you're still very new right
when you've only been learning to code
for like a year or less like you
definitely don't want to be wasting your
time applying in networking but when you
do hit that threshold where you feel
like you're qualified for junior
positions whether it's front end backend
full stack doesn't matter once you feel
like you're confident and ready for that
Junior position um you don't want to do
this right you do not want to switch
to 0% learning and building and 100%
applying and networking instead I
recommend somewhere around 50/50 and it
depends for everyone but you want to be
splitting your
time amongst these two tasks and this
doesn't mean every waking hour of the
day right you've got 8 hours sleeping 16
hours awake that doesn't mean 8 hours
learning in building and 8 hours
applying Network working um what it
means is whatever time you have
available to dedicate to your future
career as a programmer that's the time
you should be splitting right if you
have a full-time job already and you
can't quit because you need to pay bills
like I probably wouldn't even recommend
quitting um maybe you've only got a
couple hours at night every night and a
few hours on the weekend let's say 10
hours a week or 20 hours a week that's
the time that I'd recommend splitting
between learning and building and
continuing to apply in work now the next
strategy that I want to talk about again
not a nitty-gritty tactic we'll get into
those later but kind of a highle
strategy that will inform a lot of the
other stuff that we're going to do in
this course as we learn how to get a job
is
signal versus
noise okay what does that mean let's
draw it um have you ever seen a
heartbeat
monitor the heartbeat monitor usually
looks something like this you've got
kind of this little this little squiggly
line and then it shoots up when a
heartbeat happens and it kind of goes
back to Baseline then it shoots up again
on the next heartbeat right this how
doctors monitor your heartbeat in
hospital you've probably seen it in
movies right well these big these big
bursts or these big mountains in the
graph represent signal right this is
what the doctor cares about he wants to
know when do
individual heartbeats happen right and
then these other parts down here this
little squiggly stuff that happens along
along the way is it just goes up and
down very slightly that's the
noise right so here we've clearly got a
signal and then all this crap that's
just kind of again just kind of little
squiggly ups and downs in the graph
that's just
noise and when when we talk about signal
and noise we're kind of we're kind of
talking about what we care about and
what we don't care about right we want
signal we want to know when something
interesting is happening something that
we care about is happening and we want
to kind of ignore the noise it just
doesn't matter very much now there is an
analogy here I'm not just teaching you
about heartbeats for no reason when
you're looking for a job and this really
applies to any job but you know for us
we're talking about programming jobs
when you're applying for a job your
primary objective should be to provide
as much signal as you can to your
potential employer that you're a really
good hire right and your employer is
trying to sift through a ton of noise
right they're getting 50 60 100
applications it's super noisy they're
trying to dig through very quickly many
many applications many resumés right and
they're trying to find the signal right
who is the best in class who should I
hire right and you should be thinking
how can I provide upfront signal to this
potential employer that I know what I'm
doing right you don't want to have to
make them dig through like every nook
and cranny of your GitHub profile before
they find something interesting that
you've done right you want to put the
interesting things that you've done
front and center you want to call
attention to them right you want to make
it as easy as possible for anyone who
might hire you to find out that you've
done some incredible stuff that you've
built some really cool projects and that
you know what you're doing and that
you're the right person for this job so
to reiterate noise are the little bumps
on the graph the little bumps that can
be potentially confused for signal right
and they're what makes it hard for the
person who cares about the signal to
find the signal so your job is to make
everything that's impressive about you
super obvious and to stand out from the
rest because that's really how you're
going to land that first job is just by
standing out being impressive and making
it really really easy for the person
who's eventually going to hire you to
figure out that you're the right one
because they have a ton of noise to sift
through so you're probably sick of
hearing from me at this point let's cut
over to my friend TJ who I have on the
backend banter podcast to talk about
exactly this idea and how projects can
provide a lot of signal up
front yeah I think there's sort of a
twofold way that you get helped by doing
open source stuff the first one is I
think when you actually build something
you accelerate your learning a lot so by
like actually doing you you learn a lot
more than just by like reading or taking
a class or whatever not that those
things those things often provide you
sort of like the Baseline that that you
need to be effective at building um but
then like eventually you need to move on
to building things and then so that's
like the one side is you do learn a lot
of new things and then the the other
side is it does open up connections and
like it's a way in in a lot of ways it's
a much easier thing to put on your
resume because you can point to
something that someone can go look at
instead of just like saying well I
worked at Corporation X for three years
I was managing several projects that
shipped and delivered on time and you
what everyone's like okay but I don't
know what any of those things do or look
like or whether they're still running
all I have is your side of the store you
know so if instead it's like you know
someone is out there using your stuff
that you make that's a big signal to say
that you're able to ship code that
people find useful which ultimately like
unless you're rting hascal you that's
sort of like a goal of the company I
think now the last thing I'm going to
say about strategy before we start
diving into some more n gritty tactics
is that
nobody nobody's going to give you a job
out of pity I don't know a better way to
say that right like I I don't know a
nicer way to say that um but I've met
people online who seem to think that the
best way to get a job is to write a big
soab story about how no one will give
you a job and to send that to hiring
managers right I've worked as a hiring
manager and I've received kind of these
sad stories and they are sad like it
pulls at my heartstrings that someone
spent all this time learning to code and
they're having a hard time getting a job
like that is sad but that strategy right
of sending
out what are essentially just sad
stories about how you can't find a job
that is a terrible strategy for getting
your first job I've I've literally never
heard of this working and the reason
should be fairly obvious if I'm a hiring
manager and I have a new job that I'm
hiring for and I get 20
applications and one person tells me you
should hire me because I'm having a
really hard time and I really need this
job and nobody else will hire me if I'm
trying to be fair and objective and not
discriminatory in my hiring it is my job
to hire the most qualified person now
that message they sent me might not
outright disqualify them but by them
coming forward with the idea that nobody
wants to hire me that's anti-al that's
really bad right that's just telling me
that's just giving me social proof it's
like an anti- testimonial it's giving me
negative social proof that nobody wants
to hire this person why should I want to
hire this person maybe they're not very
good so rather than try to get a job out
of pity you really want to come to the
table right you really want to put
forward on your resume on your social
media like you want to put forward this
air of confidence because that's what
people that are hiring you want to see
they want to see someone that feels
confident that they can add value to the
business and that they're the best hire
that's what's actually going to help you
get the job so try to be confident I
know that can be hard right especially
as a junior developer maybe you're not
super confident in your skills but that
also ties into why I said really as
you're searching for a job you should be
continuously learning and building
because nothing builds up your
confidence like having some really
amazing portfolio projects that you can
show off right something tangible that
proves that you know what you're doing
so you don't need to be a jerk right you
don't need to be cocky but you do want
to put forward this air of confidence
it's like any negotiation that you've
probably seen in the movies right you
don't want to come to the negotiation
table acting desperate because then
you're going to get a really bad deal or
frankly no deal at all right you want to
come to the table with confidence that
you can add value to your future
employer and that's going to be what
helps you the most it's time to get your
portfolio projects in order now
everything we do in this course build a
resume work on GitHub profiles LinkedIn
profiles none of that will work if we
don't have a really good project or two
that we can optimize and make look
really good because that's really what
we're going to be showing off in all of
those other places assuming this is your
first programming job that you'll ever
have you need a standin for work
experience right with your second third
fourth programming job the best thing on
your resume is your previous work
experience that can shows that you know
what you're doing if you don't yet have
a job on your resume the best thing that
you can have are great portfolio
projects because they kind of act as a
standin for work experience right the
hiring manager can just go look at the
project and see if you know what you're
doing now I want you to right now choose
one project that's going to be your main
portfolio project most hiring managers
don't have time to look through 20 or 30
different GitHub repositories they're
going to want to look at one project
that you've built and honestly a lot of
the decision- making that goes on inside
their head is going to be based off of
that one project if you don't have one
yet that's okay I'm going to spend some
time in this chapter talking about how
you can choose a good project or how you
can enhance an existing project but you
just keep in mind you might want to
pause this video bookmark it um when
we're done talking about that so you can
go make all of those enhancements and
then come back and finish the rest of
the course so assuming that you either
have a bunch of projects and you need to
pick which one's going to be your main
portfolio project or you don't yet have
a good project let's talk about a couple
rules of thumb for picking a good
project idea the first one is that you
really want to stand out so you don't
want this main portfolio project to be
something that you followed a tutorial
for online like that's a huge red flag
it's pretty obvious when you built
something through a tutorial you don't
want it to be something simple like a
Spotify clone or a Twitter clone you
really don't want to be a clone right
that's that's not very interesting um
you also want to avoid like really
common types of projects like
tic-tac-toe games and to-do apps you
want to choose something that really
stands out and is unique and this is
like I really can't stress this point
enough when someone's reading your
resume and looking at your projects the
only thing they're going to see is like
a oneline description of what your
project is and you kind of want that to
grab
attention if it's some something that
solves a real problem that you
experience in your life especially if
it's a unique or interesting problem
those are the kinds of projects that are
a good candidate for your portfolio
project so let me tell you about a
project that I did when I was in college
that I think is a pretty good example of
something that's unique I wrote a python
script that took as input an MP3 file
and as output generated sheet music of
well a drum beat it was actually a
pretty simple program but that's the
interesting thing your program doesn't
have to be the most sophisticated piece
of technology ever written you really
want to maximize for the interesting
Factor because that's what's going to
get someone reading about your project
and calling you on the phone to talk
about it more right so this project that
I built you essentially would sit down
and you could play a drum beat into a
microphone Throw That MP3 file through
my python script and it would spit out a
semi accurate uh version of what that
drum beat would look like in sheet music
it wasn't the most accurate thing it
certainly wasn't the most useful thing
but it was something that was
interesting and it did work right so it
got people when they were looking at my
resume to ask follow-up questions about
the project like oh that's really
interesting I've never seen anything
like that before like what did you use
to detect the loudness spikes in the
music did you use any libraries what did
you import right it got us talking about
the project and that's really the
position that you want to be in so try
to think of something that's interesting
right I also built a Starcraft 2 battle
simulator at one point again not a
sophisticated piece of technology it was
a python script and had hardcoded values
for all of the different units in the
game right Marines do 50 damage per
bullet and Marauders do 75 damage per
bullet or whatever it was and it was
just a command line tool right it didn't
even have a front end it wasn't a full
application but again it was interesting
some of my interviewers liked Starcraft
it was something that we could talk
about so really try to come up with
something interesting unique and
something that's big enough that you do
have to solve some technical problems
because again when people do ask the
follow-up questions you want to be able
to have somewhat of an interesting
conversation about code so the next
thing I want to talk about is kind of
just opening your mind to all of the
different types of projects uh that you
can build if you're a front-end
developer you might be thinking well you
know I could build like a portfolio site
I could do something with HTML CSS and
JavaScript and if you're really focused
on front end development that might be
the best option um although you'd
probably want to build some sort of
interesting web application if you're a
backend developer there are some other
options that I want to open your mind to
so for example this is a library right
which to be fair you could totally do a
library on the front end and publish to
npm but in in this case um this is a go
library that I built that actually helps
me get a job as a senior developer and
the interesting thing is this is
actually an incredibly simple Library um
if you spent some time looking through
it assuming you have some basic
familiarity with go you'd be like wow I
could build this this is actually no big
deal um but it's kind of cool because it
demonstrates a that you know how to code
um it's naturally interesting to go
developers because it's about
performance in the standard Library
which is kind of interesting it also
demonstrates that I know how to design a
decent API uh which is something and
when I say API I don't mean like a rest
or a crud API I mean like a good Library
API like I know how to encapsulate the
complex logic and expose only the parts
of the library to the end user of the
library that I want to right so there's
like some pretty interesting things
going on there um but it's also
inherently very unique right it's not
like a to-do app or something like this
so anyways the purpose of this Library
um is actually really straightforward
basically the standard time.time type in
go can take up to 24 bytes of memory
which is quite a bit um and that's kind
of needed for some of the advanced
features that it offers but I wrote this
Library um because in in in this Library
a time stamp only takes four bytes of
memory uh which is significantly less
right you can save like 80% of your
memory um but it does have the
limitation of it can only represent time
stamps from the year 1970 up to
2106 right um but it's a fairly
well-designed Library if I do say so
myself it matches the same API it has
all the same like functions and methods
as the standard
time.time um so the point I'm getting at
is I really think you should consider
building a library if you've built a lot
of applications in the past building a
library is a good way to stand out again
most applicat don't build libraries they
just build applications so something to
think about another thing you should
consider again especially if you're
looking for more kind of backend or data
related positions is a command line tool
right you can avoid the all the
complexity of HTML CSS and JavaScript if
you're looking for backend positions by
building an interesting command line
tool that generates you know maybe maybe
an interesting report right maybe it
pulls data from different sources on the
web and generates a really nice Excel
file or Google sheet as output um
anything dealing with interesting or
esoteric data right you think of video
games are always an interesting source
of data or various apis like stock apis
think about what you could do with a
command line tool that can also be a
really great source of inspiration if
you don't want to just build another web
app so to sum up you've probably built a
lot of projects some projects are good
for learning things like Spotify clones
or Twitter clones or you know to-do apps
they're good for learning they're not
good for your portfolio right so spend
some extra time if you don't yet have a
project get started on one bookmark this
video come back when it's ready um if
you do have one just try to pick one
that's kind of going to stand out on the
page has an interesting title now we're
going to cut to another clip from the
back in Baner podcast this time Theo
Brown was my guest and he explains not
only why building projects is one of the
best things you can do for networking
getting to know people in the industry
and generally just getting noticed in
order to get a job but also how building
projects is the best thing you can do
for your own personal learning
especially once you already have an
understanding of all the
fundamentals what I recommend for
beginners always I have a video I made
called your goals kind of suck because
as beginners as engineers in general we
suck at goal setting and that's the
thing you should be focused on is
setting realistic goals that aren't
necessarily about the code because I
want to learn JavaScript I'm going to be
a JavaScript engineer that's a goal
that's an absolutely terrible you're
going to fail type goal that's like
imagine a skateboarder says I want to be
a professional skateboarder no you don't
get good because you want to be a
professional you get good because you
have specific tricks you want to learn
and you're down to hit the ground over
and over again until you get good at it
you certainly don't get good at
skateboarding by watching a bunch of
skateboard tutorials on YouTube and
thinking about it all day or certainly
not going to University and sitting in a
class or somebody tells you which
chapters of a book to read about
skateboards you get good by getting your
reps in you got to hit the ground over
and over again trying to do something
specific a good example of a goal for an
early engineer is I really like this
video game there's some math in it
that's annoying to do I want to build a
calculator to keep track of these events
in this game that's a fantastic first
goal because you will know when it's
done with a traditional like the the
common type of goal like I'm going to
learn JavaScript when are you done
learning JavaScript because I've been
writing JavaScript for 15 years now and
I'm not done learning JavaScript so it's
so important to have that natural I've
achieved my goal like end point and I
find that most goals for engineers
especially beginner goals don't have a
point where they can reflect and say yes
I have achieved this which makes it a
bad goal I'm a massive advocate for
Project based learning especially in
this field I would argue in almost all
Fields it's a strong way of doing things
but in software Dev in particular it's
the only way you're not going to go
insane like you cannot learn goang you
can learn how to build X in goang and
you can build X and goang and use x and
be proud of it but you can't learn going
you can't learn JavaScript you can't
learn these things you can learn how to
use them for specific things absolutely
almost all the best Engineers I know are
people who only learn to code because
they had some specific problem they had
to solve like one of my favorite
Engineers is an engineer named Jason
doton he's the founder of the UR Brad
mental health charity he's actually like
if I recall a certified therapist and
got really into mental health through
his World of Warcraft Guild that became
a charity that now became this like huge
way for people to get their first
therapist and help them out financially
if they need it and organization wise if
they don't it's such a cool or I love
them he started looking into getting a
website made for them and like the
lowest quote he could get for a
Charity's website was like
$400,000 he's like the it can't be that
hard to build a website right and taught
himself from scratch modern web dev and
now he's like one of the best Tailwind
Engineers I know he's really into
typography and typ setting in particular
he's just nerdy about it and like
regularly files PRS to my projects just
fixing things he's the best and he like
onboarded himself to that point in under
three months solo and re he had one
engineer friend who used to work at
twitch with me that he quickly
superceded and that friend was like yo
man I'm sorry I I you know more about
this than me now can I put you in touch
with my friend Theo he might be able to
help because you're using his nextjs
thing so he got thrown into my circle he
was still using vanilla JS so he rewrote
his project and typescript over the
weekend he became a huge typescript
advocate after that point but like he
got good because he had a problem to
solve and he knew when it was solved he
needed a website for his charity so that
people could sign up join the guild and
do what they need to find a therapist
and he had that very Noble driving goal
pushing him to learn how to code and
there's no way you can do better than
that and then I just want to reiterate
one project is really what you should be
focused on it's okay to list two or
three projects on your resume but
there's you really should be spending
the majority of your effort the lon
share of your effort on one single
project because one really impressive
project is way better than 10 mediocre
projects right 10 or 20 or 30 kind of
lackluster low effort projects are not
going to land you a job but one really
good project defin definitely can so
once you're done with your project all
the code is written and you're really
happy with where that part of the
project is at the coding part it's
really important to document the project
and put it somewhere publicly accessible
when I say document what I'm really
talking about is a read me so I'm here
on this lesson in the course on boot Dev
that talks about the readme and I really
just want to show you um kind of what
the sections of a good readme look like
so I would argue that in almost all
cases your projects read me should have
a great title a great
description a section that talks about
the why of the project right the
motivation the goal the thing the
project is doing that's hopefully
interesting um how to quickly get
started with the project so in the case
of a library it would be like how to
install it right npm install or go get
or whatever um and how to to start using
it in your application if it's an
application it might be like hey I'm
publicly hosting this at this URL you
can go look at it right um or it could
be instructions for how to clone down
the repo locally and run the project
especially if it's like a CLI tool or
something like that um a usage guide so
this is actually like a more in-depth
guide that goes through some of the more
granular features and details of the
project and then this one's kind of
optional but um a little section of the
readme that explains how anyone could
contribute to your public repository if
they want to so first let's talk about
your Project's title really quick um
this is actually something that a lot of
new developers uh swing and Miss on you
the last thing you want to do is make
your title downplay right or undersell
how interesting your project is so for
example if you made a to-do app the last
thing you want to name your project is
toy to-do app or or test to do app it it
makes it look like it's just something
that you were kind of doing on the side
to figure out or you know is something
that you were doing for learning
purposes when really you should be
building a project that can be used in
production that you're proud of remember
your goal here is to communicate to
employers that you can build production
ready software if you built a project
that I don't know zips up directories in
you know dotzip extension and compresses
them in some weird way don't call it
test zipping CLI application call it
Zippy right something memorable and
personal and that makes it look like a
real project so your title is just the
name of your project your description
should be like one two or three
sentences that just explains what the
project is and it should really be as
simple and as clear and concise as
possible because the person reading you
read me like you've only got a few
seconds to grab their attention so you
really want to nail this description um
and again and please refrain from
downplaying your work with using words
like just or test uh that's it's or
practice like that it ruins the whole
feel we're going for production ready
project that's what we're trying to put
out into the world um so for example if
you had an app called zip Zod right you
might write this is zip Zod a command
line tool for zipping and unzipping
files with an ultra low memory footprint
right very clear very concise says what
it does has a bit of personality this is
the kind of description that you want
and in fact I'm going to jump over to
this is one of my personal projects
actually G rabbit
mq um it's a well I'm not even going to
tell you what it is in my own words I'm
just going to read the read me right so
my title is go rabbit mq it's actually
not the best title ever it's
extremely uh descriptive this is a go
client for the rabbit
mq uh you know message bus system
I could have been more creative here
made it a little more fun um but the
description is not bad it says rapper of
Rapid mq amqp go which is a a well-known
amqp message protocol library that
provides reconnection logic insane
defaults right that's all it is it wraps
this other library and it provides
reconnection logic insane defaults we're
going to cut to my friend James qqu who
I had on my podcast to talk a little bit
about why you really should not use
words like just or toy to describe your
project want to keep those out of our
titles and
descriptions yeah I I love that you
brought up like people early on applying
for roles and and which side of the
humility and confidence they maybe lack
or have too much of and I so for context
I've taught two rounds of a boot camp
called launch code and this is we start
at like 150 people and we usually
graduate like 50 or 60 it's meant to be
like a big numbers thing and then how
many people make it through and it's
free curriculum for people and it's a
big invol and like engagement um anyway
so I've taught 300 plus students through
boot camps over the course of a few
years and consistently across the board
I always tell people you need to be more
confident and again this is a practice
thing you need to talk about yourself
more confidently because I've almost
never in my experience of teaching boot
camp students found someone who sounds
conce did like in this in this
transition period they're they're
starting at zero right like they're
starting and and this is not something
we encounter much as adults right like
as kids we learn new sports and we try
to play the piano and we do all these
things as adults we very rarely start
from Level zero we're not used to we're
not used to doing that we're not used to
feeling like we're at the bottom of the
barrel again and so almost I mean I
can't think of a person in my teaching
career that I thought hey you need to
tone it down like you're going to you're
you're not going to you're you're going
to turn people off by the way you talk
about the things you've done and the
things you've learned so yeah practicing
that confidence and and that really just
comes down to practicing how you talk
about yourself and the things you've
done and and nitpicking with with words
that you use the easy one that I talk
about a lot is the word just I just
built this I just learned how to do blah
blah blah and and that diminishes what
you've done like very subtly but it it
it shows me that you don't have a lot of
respect for what you've done and that's
something one more as side and then I
I'll kind of pause I run a Discord
Community called learn Bill teach and uh
this has been like a philosophy of mine
for several years of like we spend lots
of time learning as developers we use
what we learn to build stuff and then
like teach other people too and it's a
great way to continue to learn and we
have uh we have an event on every Friday
morning and it's called wins of the week
and it is specifically geared towards
people celebrating their own wins
because most of us don't spend enough
time reflecting on the good things that
we've done right like most of us finish
the week on a Friday and we reflect back
we're like oh I didn't do this I didn't
do that I didn't get as far as I wanted
to with this and and we rarely ever flip
that to just appreciate well here's what
I did do and that's still a good thing
so that's what that time is specifically
dedicated for is because most people
including myself most of the time don't
take the time to really appreciate the
things we've learned the things we've
built the things we taught other people
go in kind of Full Circle there we just
don't take the time to do that and I
think that has can have a significant
influence on how you talk about yourself
and how you show up specifically when it
comes to interviews so hiring manager
has come to your portfolio project on
GitHub and they've read your title and
your description and they haven't lost
interest which is really good the title
in the description need to be fantastic
right if those aren't good you're going
to lose the person immediately and
they're going to they're going to go
away they're going to go to the next
applicant right but if those are good
the next section that they should find
is a wide section or a like motivation
or goals and really the purpose of this
section it's just like one or maybe two
paragraphs of text but it explains why
this project needs to exist in the world
right what inspired you to create this
project what problem is it really
solving so I wrote up this little
example given our ZIP Zod project says
there are a lot of ways to zip and unzip
files but none of them use so little
memory zip Zod is the zipping tool you
need for working on low memory devices
like raspberry pies I use a Raspberry Pi
as a Home Server and I was frustrated by
my inability to easily manage large
files on a small device so I built zip
Zod right so if you can tie in like a
personal story right I use x and it had
me frustrated for y reason so I built
this project right as software
developers our job is to solve real
world problems so even if it's a small
small problem that your project solves
if you're solving a real Pro a real
problem that comes across really really
well to hiring managers so try to Think
Through the motivation and again maybe
this means going back to the drawing
board and building another project uh
not that's not a problem learning and
building will always continue to make
the job search easier and easier but
just make sure that you have a really
good y section in your read me I want to
show you another example of a motivation
section on a readme that I thought was
really good so I'm on the uh HTM X repo
HTM X is a front-end Library um for
building ironically kind of serers side
web applications but anyways it's a
great project um and I'm going to go
ahead and scroll down to the motivation
section and it says why should only a
and form tags be able to make HTTP
requests why should only click and
submit events trigger them why should
only get and post be available why
should you only be able to replace the
entire screen by removing these
arbitrary constraints HTM X completes
HTML as a
hypertext fantastic motivation section
let's take a look at one more example so
this is the python websockets
Library says why should I use websockets
so notice they changed the title right
they didn't call the section motivation
or goals that's okay um but the ideas
the same right the idea is the same
we're explaining why the project was
built why it needs to exist okay they
say the development of websockets is
shaped by four principles correctness
websockets is heavily tested for
compliance with RFC
6455 continuous integration fails under
100% Branch coverage and just to note
here like you want to do good markdown
like this is a nice markdown um ordered
list and here we've hyperlink um you
know we've hyperlink some anchor text
we're not just pasting in a big nasty
link so make sure you format things
nicely um simplicity all you need to
understand is message equals await
websocket receive and await websocket do
send message so here we're just saying
like look we wanted a really simple way
to work with websockets in Python and
this is the simple API that now exists
because of this
project robustness websockets is built
for production for example was the only
library to handle back pressure
correctly before the issue became widely
known in the python
Community this is a great example of
backing up your claims anytime you make
bold claims about you know performance
or or something like that uh you're
going to want to link to the source so
you can so you can prove that um and
then finally performance memory usage is
optimized and configurable a c extension
accelerates expensive operations it's
pre-compiled for Linux Mac and windows
and packaged in the wheel format for
each system and the python version
so this is a little longer than you
probably will need for your personal
project but notice it's still pretty
concise right and this is this is
actually quite a large project python
websocket um so keep it concise but get
the message out right this project needs
to exist because blank okay next let's
talk about the quick start section now I
want to point out at this point that
when a hiring manager is reading through
your projects read
me it's actually unlikely that they're
going to take the time to like clone
your project run it all that kind of
stuff they might they might do and so I
mean you want your project to work like
I'm not saying it shouldn't work um but
I just want to prepare you for the idea
that you know title description
motivation the reason those sections are
so important is because a lot of the
people that are perusing your project
are not actually going to take the time
to clone it and run it um but that is
the purpose of this section is to make
it super super easy to use it or at
least super easy to see how it would be
used right um so let's take a look at at
a quick example I've actually included
the the raw markdown for an example
quick start section uh section of your
read me just in case you're still a
little fuzzy on how markdown works okay
so we've got the quick start heading
and underneath we've got another heading
it says install zip Zod using the go
tool chain so this is you know a code
block that someone can very easily copy
and paste into their terminal to install
zip Zod and then run zip Zod with an
input directory and an output file so
just very basic usage example this is a
fantastic quick start it's only a few
lines of code to copy and paste into the
terminal and then whoever's using it is
up and running with your project now if
your project isn't a CLI tool um but
it's instead a web app then I would
recommend hosting it somewhere on the
public internet right because then your
quick start section gets even simpler
and even easier you just kind of Link
this is a markdown hyperlink right kind
of just link to your live running app
and maybe add some explanatory text like
upload your file you get a download link
when it's done so here's a real world
example of what I'm talking about this
is the Discord go um the go client
library for Discord um it's actually
just a community library but it's
probably the most popular one um and its
quick start guide is kind of broken down
into a couple of different sections but
again the idea is the same so we've got
this installing section and it's got a
simple command I can copy and paste into
my terminal to install Discord go and
then the usage is like okay just import
the package at the top of your go file
and here's some code that you can copy
and paste into your app to get going
with the Discord client next up is the
usage section and deceptively this might
feel a lot like the quick start section
but this is really where you want to
brag about any advanced features or
special things that your app does you
kind of want to get technical with the
description so in the case of a command
line tool that zips up um files you
might have a list of all of the
different available flags that your
command line tool supports right and
you'll probably want to include a bunch
of examples of how somebody can go about
using all of those different options so
again here we're just going a little bit
deeper and
I would argue that for a personal
portfolio project what you're really
trying to optimize for here is you want
to show off all the cool stuff you built
right it is about helping users of your
project like you do want the
documentation to be accurate but at the
end of the day you really want to be
showing off look at all this cool stuff
that I built the last section I want to
talk about is the contributing section
so this one should probably be at the
very bottom of your read me and there's
a couple of goals here um one one is
when you add a contributing section
there is a chance that other people out
there online will find your public
repository and want to contribute
changes back to it which is super cool
the more attention your repository gets
the more stars it gets like that only
helps you right you're maintaining a
larger project that looks more
impressive frankly but the second reason
that you want a contributing section is
so that you can explain to hiring
manager or really frankly anyone that's
reading you read me
how they can actually get involved with
the project on a technical level like if
they wanted to pull down and run the
code right so the usage section and the
quick start were really about being a
user of your project right which in the
case of a library is pulling it down and
running the code but in the case of like
a CLI tool or a web application they may
not interact with the code at all in
those sections of your documentation so
this section in the case of a web app
might actually be clone down the repo
and run you know npm run Dev to get a
local development environment up and
running so we're trying to show them how
to run the code and and really what's
going to happen is if they're really
interested in you if they really like
your project they might actually clone
down the repo run the code and poke
around through all the different code
files in their own development
environment like this is something that
I've done as a hiring manager when I'm
really interested in a project because
you know I read through the rest of the
read me and it really peaked my interest
I certainly don't pull down every
project of every resume of every person
that applies for my jobs but when I get
to the point where I'm ready to call
someone to bring them in for an
interview I might pull down their code
and actually poke through it so let's
take a look at this example um
contributing heading First Step clone
the repo and I really like when the
instructions are super explicit like
it's impossible for the person reading
your documentation to mess up right like
we've spelled out the entire git clone
command we've told them to change
directory into the directory once
they've cloned it we've given them the
build Command right in this case this is
how you run the project locally this is
how you run the tests if you want here's
a description of how to submit a poll
request right be be very detailed and
very explicit um the last thing you want
to happen is for someone to be super
interested in your project clone down
your repository and not be able to
figure out how to get it to compile they
might even at worst think your project
is broken because they can't get it to
compile and run so you really want to
spell this out and make it as simple as
you can it's time to talk about GitHub
profiles I'm a big believer in GitHub
when it comes to your job search if I
had to stack rank LinkedIn and GitHub in
terms of which is more important for
your job search as a programmer I think
I'd actually put GitHub above LinkedIn
in terms of if you could only have one
really good one I'd take the GitHub so
in this chapter after we're going to
talk about making an amazing GitHub
profile and the first thing that I want
to start out with is that the principle
is the same we're really trying to
provide a ton of upfront signal to
whoever's looking at our GitHub profile
right we want to show them that we know
what we're doing as quickly as we can so
they don't have to spend a lot of time
digging through the profile to see all
the cool stuff that we've done and the
very first thing we're going to want to
do is make a good impression with our
profile itself and and really what I
mean by that is we just don't want to
come across as a bot and one of the
easiest ways to not look like a bot is
just to have a profile picture right
most Bots don't take the time to add a
unique profile picture so just by not
having that default blocky colorful
GitHub image it adds some signal I'd
also say like take the time to get a
good photo even if it takes an hour or
two you don't need to go hire a
professional photographer or anything
like that but get a good picture of
yourself smile ideally don't look angry
um but you just want a good profile
picture because you're going to use this
for your GitHub for your LinkedIn you
could even throw it up on your Twitter
um it's going to be useful to have a
nice head shot of yourself so just make
it high effort and it's going to help a
lot so here's an example of my GitHub
profile again it's just a picture of my
face not a big deal you don't need to
look amazing I certainly don't um but at
least I'm happy and you can kind of see
that I'm a real human that's really all
we're going for here um probably don't
use your favorite anime character I mean
again I'm sure people have gotten jobs
with with pictures like that but I just
I I think it kind of makes you look less
professional so I'd go for a picture
yourself next is you're going to want to
add let me see if I can zoom this in a
little bit more you're going to want to
add your full name right just as it
appears on your resume um this is really
easy to update in GitHub if you made
your GitHub a while ago like say when
you first started learning to code you
may have like added a joke name or a
name that you used as your Gamertag when
you were 17 like
the point is you can update this you
don't have to leave it as whatever you
used when you happen to create your
GitHub account ages ago right the same
goes for your username um I'd highly
recommend picking a username that's like
pretty tame kind of just probably maybe
your first name dot last name something
like that right my name's Lane Wagner so
Wags Lane again just pretty easy um you
know robot killer 69 might not be the
best GitHub username this stuff isn't
going to make or break whether or not
you get hired but it's like let's just
go over all the little things and get
them right so that we know this isn't
the reason we weren't hired right we
might as well check all the boxes it
only takes a few minutes next be sure to
add a quick bio right I've got my bio
right here I like go I tolerate
JavaScript and python haha right super
funny I have a great personality um at
Wags Lane everywhere right something
super quick ideally maybe shove in a
little bit about what you enjoy what you
don't enjoy show that you have a little
bit of Personality as a developer um but
definitely fill it out again it's just
another little thing that shows that
you're a real human that's interested in
development lastly before we move on
GitHub gives you a really easy way to
like Link in organization the city that
you're from Um this can actually be
really important especially if you
happen to be from a tech Hub like don't
hide that right put that front and
center if you're in San Francisco you
might as well advertise it um personal
site Twitter
um another personal site like just fill
this stuff in if it makes sense if you
don't tweet a lot like don't put your
Twitter who cares or if you're
embarrassed about what you tweet don't
put it if you don't have a personal site
that's okay you don't need one um I
would say in the general case you
probably want to put your location um
just so that when you do apply to local
jobs they'll be able to see that you're
local which will give you an edge over
you know all of the different remote
workers that might be trying to apply
for that same job feel free to poke
around my GitHub if you want an example
of an okay put together GitHub it's it's
not the best GitHub in the world but
I've at least spent some time um I'd
also recommend taking a look at Eddie
zad's GitHub um Eddie's a friend of mine
and he does a ton of stuff on GitHub and
he has an absolutely amazing GitHub
profile so if you want an example of
something that's really really good be
sure to check his out next thing I want
to talk about is that GitHub has this
really cool feature called a profile
read me so this section here this intro
text is actually generated from a very
specific GitHub repository let me show
you how that works so this is my
github.com Wags Lane page and this this
repository is github.com
waglan Wags Lane in other words my
username is wag Lane and I went and
created a new repository in my account
called Wags Lane and when you do that
when you have a repository and your
username that match that
repository it's read me right this this
uh this read me that's in the repository
will be used to populate this section of
your profile page it's kind of just a
conventional thing that GitHub has put
into place so if you want to create a
little intro like this that's how you do
it create a repository in your GitHub
that's named the same thing as your
username and that read me will populate
now my intro is actually probably not
the best example of what you want in
your intro just because I'm not a junior
developer looking for work at the moment
I'd actually recommend and this is what
I do recommend uh in the of associated
section on botev let me get this out of
the
way I recommend that your intro section
have maybe one or two paragraphs that
kind of outlines a bit about your story
and how you got into programming in the
first place and like everything we do in
this course try not to be generic and
vague you don't want to say something
like I'm a passionate web developer that
loves writing tests and I want to work
on cool projects like that's the most
Bland uninteresting thing that you could
possibly put in your intro and if that's
what you're going to put like just don't
even have an intro at all what you want
to put is something that kind of shows
your personality maybe shows some of the
opinions or some of the the special
things that you've been learning as
you've been getting into vment so I'm
going to go ahead and just like read
this example that I wrote up um I've
been enjoying web development for the
first time ever since I built my first
go project stack rapper the Consolidated
tool chain makes me want to leave the
JavaScript ecosystem behind for good
right so obviously this example is
someone who's been learning go they've
decided they don't really like
JavaScript but it's really good to
inject those sorts of opinions into your
writing especially if the kind of jobs
that you're applying for would agree
with the kind of opinions that you're
putting forth right like so you probably
wouldn't want to write this if you're
applying for JavaScript positions but if
you're applying for go positions and you
genuinely believe this it goes a long
way to kind of signal that again that
you're human and that you have opinions
and that you've you've been through this
stuff right you appreciate you
appreciate goes Consolidated tool chain
right like it's like a way to show your
experience without just saying that
you're an experienced go developer again
so Bland and boring
cool I'm currently on the lookout for a
role in backend web development ideally
writing go or python I'd especially love
to work at a startup on a tight-knit
team where I can make an impact quickly
if you're hiring let's chat I think this
is a pretty good example right and um
again it's about bringing your
personality forward and also about kind
of niching down like if you're already
finding a niche in the types of jobs
that you're applying for like let's say
you're only applying really for backend
development positions in Python you you
might as well in your intro just mention
that that's what you're looking for
because it will set you apart from all
of the folks that just have a super
generic I'm looking for any programming
position um it'll set you apart from
them right when when someone wants to
hire a back-end python developer they're
much more likely to hire someone who in
their resume says I'm a backend python
developer right that's much more likely
than them hiring someone who just says
I'm a full stack web developer and I use
every technology next let's talk about
pinning reposit
so right below your intro right your
profile read me you're able to pin
repositories and if you are getting your
first programming job my guess is you
probably only have one two or maybe
three repositories that you want to pin
the most important thing is to take your
primary repository the project that
you're most proud of right that we
talked about in the last chapter and
make sure you pin that one first right
in my case it's this G rabbit mq client
like I put the most work into that
repository I really want it to be the
one that recruiters that hiring managers
are clicking on and taking a look at
right now I've been developing for a
decade now and I have a few other public
repos that I like to show off um in this
case there's five one of them is
actually just a Blog um but you don't
need five and it's better to have a
fewer number of good projects than a
larger number of mediocre projects
because realistically someone that looks
at my profile like they're going to
check out one two again maybe three
projects so don't go for quantity here
go for quality and really only pin the
stuff that you're super proud of next I
just want to mention your GitHub heat
map now I don't want to brag but my
GitHub heat map is pretty good um if you
can't tell I code nearly an unhealthy
amount um I think I've only missed like
two days in the last in the last year
um I kind of cheat though so like first
of all like do not hold yourself to the
standard um I cheat in that uh my
blogging and a lot of the uh kind of
project management work and even some of
the way I organize my life I just do in
git and use GitHub for it so I just like
I'm so used to git and I love markdown
that I just use GitHub so much and
that's that's why you know my profile
looks like this um you do not need an
amazing GitHub heat map in order to get
hired so like I just want to be very
clear about this this is the least
important thing we've talked about so
far but I'm going to mention it because
it's really easy to come here and change
your contribution settings to also allow
for private contributions and that means
if you've had a job in the past or if
you've worked for a client where even
even if the repo you were working on was
Private it will show
those contributions in grein here it's
not like it's not going to violate
privacy it's not going to show what the
changes were but at least it will show
that you were coding and so that's a
nice little trick um to kind of boost
your heat map and show that you write a
lot of code all right before we leave
GitHub behind us for the moment I want
to talk about stars so at the top of
your repository you'll be able to click
on this Stars
Tab and this shows everything you've
starred so this actually is not super
important right so I I'm just pointing
this out so you don't get confused this
is all of the stuff that you as a GitHub
user have
starred the thing that might be more
interesting to
employers is who's starred you or how
many stars you've received so for
example my G rabbit mq um library has
619 Stars not it's not crazy it's not
this like huge open source project but
like that's pretty good for a personal
project um frankly anything over just
like 10 or 20 stars is pretty impressive
because it means somebody um cared about
your project now again I want to point
out getting GitHub stars is not critical
you do not need to spend a lot of your
time going around and promoting your
projects but if you do have a project
that you think other people could
benefit from especially if it's like a
library it might be worth taking the
time to post about it on Reddit right or
drop a link on Hacker News if you think
it's Unique um because if you can fairly
easily get a few stars um it does act as
social proof it's kind of like a
testimonial that hey this guy built
something that's interesting and I like
it right so having stars on your GitHub
repo does help but I wouldn't waste too
much of your time trying to chase down
the stars if there's some loow hanging
fruit um then again maybe go Post in
some different communities just to kind
of get the project off the ground um but
don't spend too much time here it's time
to talk about your LinkedIn profile now
LinkedIn is probably your second most
important social media presence if
you're looking to get a job as a
developer uh GitHub really being the
most important and I stand behind that I
I know GitHub is not really a social
presence but when we think about you
know profiles on online platforms I
definitely put GitHub above LinkedIn if
you're a developer obviously that's not
true for other roles like marketing and
sales but if you're a programmer I'd
rather you have a good GitHub than a
good LinkedIn so in this section because
we already talked about GitHub we're
going to be talking about LinkedIn and
just know that a lot of the stuff you
did on your GitHub profile will
translate over to the LinkedIn profile
so this section might feel a little bit
faster right for example you already
went and got a good profile photo so
we're just going to use the same one on
LinkedIn now one more caveat I want to
add there is that when a recruiter or an
HR person is looking you up they will
probably go to your LinkedIn over your
GitHub if you're in the later stages of
the application process with like the
hiring manager or the other Engineers on
the team they're more likely to check
out out your GitHub they'll probably
look at both but my guess is they'll
spend more time on your GitHub when I
was a hiring manager I certainly did
okay let's pound out a few basic things
so I'm here on my LinkedIn profile and
you'll notice I have a profile picture
again don't use the default hopefully
you already have a good profile picture
from GitHub just upload it here one main
difference is that on LinkedIn you get a
banner image um not super important you
probably could leave this blank and get
away with it but as long as we're doing
everything the right way you might as
well come up with a banner photo um if
you have a photo of like you at a
conference that's fantastic or at a
Meetup those kind of photos do really
well um or just like you doing some
hobby that you have right like maybe
it's a shot of you at the beach with
your family whatever um the the purpose
of the pro of the banner image isn't
necessarily to like show what an expert
you are um it's more just to again to
show that you're a human that you're not
a bot and that you've put some amount of
work into your profile um um and then
also make sure you add your location
again um LinkedIn
is well I guess this is the first time
I'm saying this but it's important to
understand that LinkedIn is not just a
social platform for sharing like a
resume it's also one of the biggest
recruiting and hiring Platforms in the
world and all of the fields that you
fill in on LinkedIn are going to be used
by recruiters to find you so you want to
make sure that all of this stuff is
accurate and up to date and for example
I am technically in American Fork Utah
which is a small town outside of Salt
Lake I'm not going to put that I'm going
to put Salt Lake City metropolitan area
because that's where all the jobs are
right so there's there's little tricks
you can do like that to kind of you know
you want to fudge your way into the big
city but the point is you want to be um
you want to be filling out these fields
so that you get picked up when
recruiters and hiring managers are
looking for people in your area now
scrolling down the page a little bit um
let's take a look at my about section so
this is kind of like the summary of uh
at the top of a resume or on GitHub it's
it's kind of like your profile read me
right it's just one or two paragraphs
you really want to keep it short that
put your best foot forward um so it
really should look pretty similar to
whatever you put on your GitHub profile
read me albeit it's just a text field
it's not full markdown so you might have
to do some formatting changes let me
read you mine and I'll kind of explain
what I like like to see and what I don't
like to see in one of these summaries so
mine says I like to work in go
JavaScript and python um in fact let me
Zoom this in for you so you can see a
little bit
better okay let's try that I love to
work in go JavaScript and python but I'm
happy to use whatever tool is most
suited for the job at hand my two
favorite daily activities are learning
and teaching within my team and
listening to Vampire Weekend while I jam
out some code I've recently been on a
rust and Zig kick doing some stuff on
the side when I have time in those
languages I'm also interested in the
marriage of the serers side rendering
single page application world and how we
can build Client First web apps that
still have certain pages that pre-render
immediately for SEO
purposes okay so this is actually on the
longer side like I probably wouldn't go
much longer than this um but there's a
couple things here first I'm calling out
technologies that are interesting to me
now um I have you know s to 10 years of
professional experience depending on how
you you slice the the time frames a
little bit and I'm really only calling
out three different programming
languages here and down here I'm just
saying this stuff interests me right you
probably want less right like you
probably want to focus on the main
programming languages or technologies
that you're interested in in getting
jobs for because it's better to have a
profile that screams I want a job in
backend development writing go for
example then I'm a web developer that
can do anything and that might be
counterintuitive right it feels like
you're shutting yourself off from a lot
of potential jobs but what it means is
when you do go apply to those go jobs
the recruiter or the hiring manager will
read that you're super interested in go
and that puts you ahead of all the other
kind of generic applicants right the
Assumption being that youve spent a lot
more time in go and that you're really
going to enjoy the role now I will say
this second sentence here I can't
remember how long ago I wrote this by
the way uh but the second can sentence
here my two favorite daily activities
are learning and teaching within my team
and listening to Vampire Weekend while I
jam out some code the nice thing about
this is it shows a little bit of
Personality which is a thing you want to
do the not so great thing about this is
it feels really generic right learning
and teaching like who doesn't like to do
that it's it's it's kind of bland um the
more specific you can be um in general
the better because it does come across
as more human but you also want to be
specific to like stuff that will be
interesting like my hiring manager
doesn't care that I listen to Vampire
Weekend like they they don't care that
that's a band that I like right um so we
don't want to spend a lot of time on
this kind of stuff um ideally we'd be
saying things that show our personality
through the craft right so like for
example this next paragraph does a much
better job I've recently been on a rust
SL Zig kick right showing that I'm
interested in lower level programming
languages and that this is what I'm
playing around with currently and that
I've been doing a lot with server side
rendering and single page applications
so I've recently been working in a lot
of like SEO stuff that's a little more
tangible um and probably more of the
sort of thing that you'd want to include
in this section of your LinkedIn I want
to show you an example of another really
good LinkedIn profile so feel free to
look at mine it's okay um but this is
Danny Thompson he's a friend of mine um
he's big on Twitter if you're in in Tech
Twitter you you probably know who Danny
is um but he has a great LinkedIn
presence absolutely fantastic so um but
in particular I want to show you what
he's done with his experience so Danny
has been in the industry well let's just
take a look let's take a look at his
experience tab um so he's he's current
it looks like he's currently at AutoZone
he's been at front door at Google right
uh he was a a board member for um stem
in Shelby County Schools that's awesome
um he's a teaching assistant at launch
code um and this is great if you go back
far enough you can see he was a fry cook
from 2008 to 2019 now this is a question
I get a lot about like what should I put
on my LinkedIn or on my resume under the
experience section if I don't have any
experience as a
developer and we'll talk about this a
little bit more in the resume section
but for now I just want to point out
that it's actually a really good idea to
have experience on your resume or on
your LinkedIn even if it's not
programming experience because that at
least shows that you can hold down a job
that you're hardworking right that
you've been in a professional
environment in some cases uh so you're
going to want to put it and usually what
happens is as you get more and more tech
jobs you might start removing some of
the older jobs right like my resume when
I first was getting into Tech had things
like bank teller waiter at a restaurant
those were you know my my two most
recent pieces of experience they're not
on my resume anymore but they were for
the first two or three jobs because I
wanted to have a couple of entries in
that list so again Danny Thompson you
can check out his profile on LinkedIn
and follow him um it's a it's a great
example of how to craft a LinkedIn
profile a couple more sections worth
calling out are of course the education
section if you're self-taught with like
free code Camp right like this video
right here you can can actually add free
code Camp to your education section uh
the same with boot. if you're a bootd
student you can add that to your
education section of course you can add
official degrees you can add
certifications there's a lot of stuff
that you can add there so there's really
no reason to leave this blank even if
you didn't go get a traditional
four-year CS degree right there's other
things that can actually go in that
education section I'd recommend filling
it out um there's also a project section
um this is a great place to add the
project s that we recently added to our
GitHub profile right so the same exact
projects they can go here again some
recruiters and like HR folks people that
aren't developers they don't go to
GitHub so we really want to include that
here on LinkedIn now again we'll touch
more on this in the networking section
of this course but I want to just
mention it here while we're talking
about LinkedIn that uh it could be
really tempting on LinkedIn to just
connect to everyone right you just go
find everyone in the world and you start
sending cold connection requests cold
DMS um I wouldn't recommend that we'll
talk about it more later um but there's
a there's a better way to get in touch
with people right and to start building
a network than to just cold DM and ask
for things or cold connect with people
you don't know and have no reason to
connect with so uh for now again I just
recommend not doing cold connections to
people that you don't know and we'll
talk more about it in the networking
chapter now I'm back here in this
section of the course that talks about
um how to add experience to your
LinkedIn profile and I just want to
touch on this this section because I
think it's really important um it's
where I talk about being Tech adjacent
is an advantage right so we talked about
how if you worked at jobs that are not
really technically related right like
for example uh Danny Thompson was a fry
cook for many years um you still want to
include that there are a lot of jobs out
there though
that are Tech adjacent in other words
you weren't a developer but you were
working with developers or you were
using you know technical products or
software products and there's a way that
you can reword your The Experience
section like the description to kind of
emphasize anything that you did with
that was even remotely related to Tech
so let me give you some
examples if you had an IT Ops job right
so you weren't writing code but maybe
you were in charge of deploying software
then you might say something like I
worked closely with the development team
to ensure that the software was deployed
and running smoothly that was an awkward
scroll okay uh I wrote custom code to
automate deployments right or I built a
slackbot to provide real-time updates on
the status of the production environment
instead of something a little more bland
that doesn't emphasize any coding manage
production environment upgrades install
databases and analyze logs to
troubleshoot issues so you really just
want to emphasize anything that you
possibly could have had to do with code
right um and then just just one more
Point while we're here is to be as
specific and as interesting as you
possibly can so you don't want to say
things like work on a backend rest API
like that's pretty boring right or
worked on a collaborative team and
practiced leadership skills vague right
everyone everyone could claim to have
done that um used Python and JavaScript
to build an app that tracks data right
track data like like what is that what
does that mean what did you actually do
right so here's some examples of what
you could do
instead builts a media uploading service
using kubernetes Docker and go right so
super specific that handled 1,000 files
per second again super specific right
we're talking about performance now
that's fantastic it replaced the old
service that struggled to handle 100
files per second so here we're again
like providing actual numbers we're not
just saying improve performance we're
saying improve performance by how much
right that's how you get
attention I L an initiated on my team to
develop a and plan to streamline our QA
process for our react native mobile app
we reduced the average turnaround time
for a poll request approval by 50% again
very specific we're talking about the
exact Technologies we used right and we
we're saying that we made something 50%
more efficient right the QA process
that's an expensive process that people
are the companies are paying people
hourly to do um so that can save a lot
of money I built a full stack Django app
that pulls weather data in real time and
sends alerts to subscribed users in
Geographic areas at risk of severe
weather okay again specific Technologies
we're not saying tracks data we're
saying pulls weather data in real time
right that's fantastic this says sends
alerts um that could even be more
specific right sends SMS text messages
to subscribe users we just want to be as
specific as we can again because that's
what really gets attention and gets
people's heads turning it's time time to
talk about resumés now a lot of the
stuff that we're going to talk about in
this chapter about resumés will also
kind of just apply to your LinkedIn
profile and I just didn't really want to
talk about it then so just realize that
as you make updates for the copy of your
resume so like the words on the page for
your resume you'll want to probably go
back and work those updates into your
LinkedIn profile as well because at the
end of the day your rink LinkedIn
profile really is just kind of a web
form version of your resume right so
your resume
document your linkedin's the exact same
information in a web form um the nice
thing about LinkedIn of course as we
talked about earlier was just that it's
parsed by LinkedIn and since LinkedIn is
this huge job board you can be surfaced
as a candidate for jobs sort of
naturally okay um first let's talk about
the medium of the resume and what I mean
by that is I'm doing this in a Google
doc uh Google Docs are great because I
highly recommend getting your resume
reviewed either by a friend or or family
member in the industry if you know
somebody or in an online community right
so going and finding a Discord or a
slack group where you can post a copy of
your resume and get feedback and advice
from people who are in the industry on
how you can improve it right you're
going to want to put in work upfront to
get it to a good place but at that point
you should get it reviewed so Google
Docs is great because you can just share
a link to it right it's not we're not
downloading and uploading files um it's
just kind of this living document so
we're we're doing the resum in the
Google Doc and then I would highly
recommend sending it to employers as a
PDF and the main reason for that is not
everyone has an easy way to view like
Word documents like Google Docs have
their own file extension and word docs
have a different file extension some
companies use like desktop Microsoft
Word sometimes the the compatibility is
not great but you can always download a
Google doc as a PDF and Chrome or really
any modern web browser will open a PDF
so it's viewable just in a browser which
is pretty nice so to reiterate we're
editing in Google Docs we're sending to
employers as a PDF I think it's a pretty
good general rule next thing I'm going
to recommend is to make your resume
visually appealing now it doesn't need
to be the the most perfectly designed
thing in the world it doesn't need to be
this stunning Masterpiece of design
right especially if you're applying for
backend engineering positions it's just
not that important um but you do want it
to look good you don't want it to look
like it was kind of broken or that you
don't know how to format a document like
that that's bad it just kind of makes it
look like you don't know what you're
doing in general so that's a problem um
and then the reason I say you want it to
look good good might actually be the
wrong word here what I think it should
be is looking different so when I was a
hiring manager I got a lot of
applications right sometimes I'd be
sifting through 30 applications and
generally speaking of 30 appliations 20
of them would look identical just black
text on white paper formatted exactly
the same way right I'm guessing there's
some very common like black onwhite
resume template that people are finding
online
and it just makes them all sort of blend
in in your mind right as you're sifting
through these papers if a resume looks a
little unique it it sticks in your mind
so you know when HR or recruiters or
hiring managers are going through a
stack of resumés and it it could be
physically going through a stack Which
is less common these days but it could
also be you know
electronically if one sticks out
visually and they like it it's easier
for them to find it again if that makes
sense so I would just go the extra mile
find a very basic template right this
template that I used it's just got a
splash of red it's just got a splash of
red it's got a serif font for headings
and a sand serif font for like bullet
points and body text and like I think
this is really all you need again you
don't need to go spend a ton of money um
you do for the most part want it to be
plain text right these rums do get read
in by automated systems ats's applicant
tracking systems and so you do want it
to be a fairly simple text-based format
so that the machines that parse these
resumés will be able to pick out things
like the keywords now I'm over here on
the text based version of the course
we're chapter 5 lesson two where we talk
about templates right um and I have
collected a few um templates that I
think are pretty good pretty
minimalistic with a little bit of color
to help you stand out um you can use one
of these if you like or you just use
them as examples right you can just find
another template or or or or make your
own um but I think all these do a decent
job of just kind of
being text based very simple very easy
to visually parse and write contact
information is bolded you want you want
people to be able to find your contact
info um but just a little bit of blue
right in this one or in this one just a
just a little bit of Orange right and
here we've got a little bit of green so
just just don't just don't do plain
black on white that that's my take some
people might disagree right I'm not
saying that I know everything but I know
that when I'm sorting through
applications um having them all be a
little visually distinct helps me
remember which ones I liked and which
ones I want to go back to next let's
talk about the actual structure of your
resume right we've looked at a few
different templates but to be honest I
would not recommend going and finding a
template from online and just using the
structure usually those templates are
published by designers right who are
just interested in making a really
pretty resume and well that's fine you
can have a pretty resume um you really
want to get the structure right so let
me tell you a little bit about my
philosophy on this so you really should
think about your resume as a landing
page on a website or as if it were a
landing page on a website in other words
you've just got a few moments to grab
somebody's attention with your resume
there's no chance that a hiring manager
who has a 100 rums to go through is
actually going to read every single one
top to bottom and comprehend all the
information on all of them it just takes
too much time right they're going to
skim so we want to put the most
important stuff at the top and we want
to make the most most important stuff ey
catching right okay so if you've never
had a job in Tech the structure I
recommend looks like this name and
contact info at the top that's Universal
right you want someone to be able to see
your name and you want them to be able
to get in contact with you that contact
info should include things like your
GitHub and your LinkedIn absolutely and
an email address and phone
number um I would recommend putting an
email address and a phone number some
people don't do that they like want to
be DMD on LinkedIn they're worried about
getting getting their phone number out
there look I would argue that if you're
trying to get your first job in Tech um
a few spam calls is worth the cost of
getting your phone number in front of
hiring managers so that they can call
you very quickly on the phone right
we're just trying to reduce the amount
of friction that it takes someone who's
interested in hiring you uh we're trying
to reduce the amount of friction it
takes for them to get in touch with you
right we don't want the reason they
decided not to reach out just because it
was too much hassle that would be a
shame right okay um after that the About
Me section so this is like the same as
your about section on your um LinkedIn
or kind of the GitHub uh profile read me
it's going to be a very similar section
one maybe two paragraphs we're really
looking for just like three sentences
four sentences like keep it really
really short and tur we should not be
trying to take up space here and if you
have nothing interesting to say it's
actually better not to say anything at
all so really try to come up with
something interesting um a good way to
introduce
yourself um next we're going to put
skills so this should really be like a
bulleted list of items and keep in mind
that ats's applicant tracking systems
are going to be trying to parse this
data so you want to keep it pretty
simple right just we're just putting
keywords in basically right like git
GitHub JavaScript python kubernetes
postgress like all the things you've
worked with shove them in there um it it
shouldn't be crazy long um but hit the
most important things for the jobs that
you're interested in right emphasize the
stuff that you're interested in doing
dayto day okay um next portfolio
projects so again this is assuming you
are looking for your first job in Tech I
recommend putting your portfolio
projects not only above education but
also above your work experience because
those are going to be the most important
things and that's what you want anyone
looking at your resume to click through
to you want them to go look into your
projects and see what you've built this
changes if you've had a job in Tech then
the most important thing is your
experience right you want to be very
obvious and clear that hey I have four
years of experience as a developer
here's where I've worked right so you
kind of flip the portfolio projects and
the experience um in that case so in a
nutshell the whole idea is we're putting
the best stuff more towards the top the
stuff that we want someone who's
skimming our application to run into
we're putting that
near the top really briefly let's talk
about contact information again like I
said I recommend four pieces of
information at a minimum your phone
number your email address your GitHub
and your LinkedIn your GitHub and your
LinkedIn should definitely be clickable
links right again we're just removing
friction like why make it hard on the
recruiter or the hiring manager to go
look at your stuff make it simple right
so um Google Docs really any rich text
format is going to support clickable
links so you might as well hyperlink
them um and like I said before you're
going to want to include these um don't
worry too much about spam calls uh if
you get them you can always block them
um those systems work pretty well um one
last thing I will say we did touch on
this earlier but your GitHub handle
right in my case Wags Lane your LinkedIn
handle and um your email address like
these are going to be read by humans so
again if you have one that you're
embarrassed by right killer Lord 69 or
whatever um or Dabber 420 whatever I
don't care if you don't like it if it's
if it's embarrassing to you like change
it just change it just go get a new
email address um and or you know change
your handle on GitHub and Linkedin um
it's not particularly hard to do so
minimum four pieces of information there
it is once again time to talk about the
about section and I know I've mentioned
it before but I want to just go over a
few more examples um and in particular
if you want to read these examples again
you can find them on boot Dev this time
in chapter 5 of the course lesson five
okay so uh the about section of your
resume is really important especially if
you're a career switcher right so if
you're switching from in Danny
Thompson's case he has such a great
story I have to just keep bringing it up
um frying chicken right uh to becoming a
developer having just a little bit about
your story can be really exp inspiring
and it can explain like a lack of
experience on your resume cuz when
someone sees that you are um looking for
your first job in Tech they kind of want
to know what the story there is they
want to know you know did you drop out
of school did you get a CS degree did
you attend a boot camp are you switching
from being a fry cook are you switching
from a career in it operations right
they want to know what's going on okay
so don't do this I'm just going to go
ahead and read you a bad example I'm a
developer who writes Python and go I
love to hang out with my family and
write code in my spare time I'm looking
for a great company to work
for really generic not super specific
everyone's looking for a great company
to work for that whole sentence does
nothing for us right I love to hang out
with my family and write code in my
spare time okay everyone's going to
claim to write code in their spare time
I'd rather be shown that than just
having you tell me um and uh okay you
have a family that tells me a little bit
about you um and go in Python that's
kind of specific about Technologies um
but in general this is not something I'm
impressed by let's take a look at some
examples um that I think do a better job
first one I discovered a love for
software engineering three years ago
ago guess there's an extra W there we'll
fix that later three years ago when I
stumbled onto a book about Python and
started writing little scripts to
automate some of my daily tasks as a
middle school teacher okay whoa super
cool right so you're like dabbling in
code as a middle school teacher and
you're writing scripts to automate some
of your tasks like that's pretty cool um
it's a lot better than like I was sick
of my job as a middle school teacher and
I learned to code so that I could pay
the bills like that's not as interesting
this is cool right um I love teaching
but it just doesn't pay the bills these
days and I was having so much fun
writing code right so we are mentioning
it's not that it's wrong to mention that
like you'll make better money as a
developer we all know this you can you
can own up to that but it's this it's
this little tidbit about writing scripts
to automate some of my daily tasks like
that's the kind of thing you really want
to slip in to one of these um little
kind of little bio uh
sections now with several big projects
under my belt okay so we're mentioning
that we've built several large projects
and having completed several rigorous
online CS courses right okay cool so
this person's taking their education
seriously they're going and learning um
you know computer science fundamentals
that's really big it's a really big deal
I'm making a full-time switch to backend
web development so this answers a lot of
the questions around your backstory and
that's really what you're trying to do
in this
section another one coding had always
just been a hobby for me I write little
projects here and there to keep track of
D and D campaigns but I hadn't
considered it as a career path after a
couple of years as a waiter I realized I
had talent for this coding stuff and
decided to go about learning the right
way and take some in-depth Cs and
backend development courses now that
I've completed those and have several
real world projects under my belt I'm
excited for a full time career in
software engineering right so we're
getting specific again I got into coding
and I was building projects for my D and
campaigns right pretty cool I was a
waiter but I've taken a bunch of courses
I've built a bunch of projects like
that's the kind of setup we're trying to
uh we're trying to put
here I've been enjoying web development
for the first time ever since I built my
first go project sta stack rapper okay
so this is pretty cool it's call it's
calling immediate attention to what I'm
guessing is this person's Capstone
project right so if you have a really
impressive Capstone project you you want
to call attention to it you're trying to
kind of uh not hide but you're trying to
get the person reading your resume to
forget about the fact that you this is
going to be your first developer job and
get really enthralled by whatever
projects it is that you've built right I
was playing around in the world of
reactjs for a while but goes
Consolidated tool chain makes me want to
leave the JS ecosystem behind for good
right this is an interesting Tech
opinion right probably not the best
opinion to put forward if you're
applying for nextjs jobs but if you're
applying for go positions like this is a
great thing to put in here it shows that
you've been around the block and that
you really appreciate what go is about
it's like showing that you have
experience without just claiming it
right this person isn't saying I am an
experienced go developer right that's
not interesting everyone's going to
claim that but by saying I've done a lot
with react to next and I didn't like it
for this specific reason and this is the
thing I really like about go it just
shows that you have experience without
having to like just come out and say it
in a really Bland way hopefully that
makes sense I'm currently looking for a
role in backend web development ideally
writing go I'd especially love to work
at a startup on a tighten it team where
I can make an impact quickly so just
niching down a little bit you know on
the um on the types of roles you're
looking for um and then I just want to
mention this here the bootd Discord we
have a job help Channel and if you would
like to drop your resume in there you're
more than welcome to and we'll give you
feedback next I just want to mention a
couple things about your skills and
Technologies section so you really want
to be fairly concise here and let me
tell you about the stuff that you should
omit right um you really don't want to
be putting stuff in here that makes it
look like you don't have experience and
what I mean by that if you're listing
like Microsoft Word or Microsoft teams
or slack as technologies that you have
experience with like that's not
impressive like we kind of just expect
you to be able to use basic web apps so
don't put that kind of stuff here we're
really interested in what technologies
you've used as a developer so like
couple programming languages right um
maybe some databases if you're looking
for backend work um again maybe some
infrastructure stuff especially if
you're on the backend side if you're on
the front end side you might be listing
things like Tailwind CSS or bootstrap
right different frontend Frameworks that
you've worked with um here I've listed
fluent Spanish that's kind of random but
it is another skill that I have I don't
know to be honest I would probably drop
this to somewhere else in the resume um
but this this isn't a big deal it can it
can live here if we
want one thing I want to caution you
against is don't try to quantify your
skills like just just make it a list
just list your skills go JavaScript
python don't try to do anything cute
where you say well I'm a five and go and
I'm a three and JavaScript right or I'm
a I'm a two out of five in Python first
of all it makes no sense like what are
you quantifying like how much of the
language you've used like are you just
comparing yourself to others right like
where another Junior developer is a five
out of five python I'm a two out of five
that's that's obviously awful so like
just don't do it it makes very little
sense and it's one of those things that
not only will be kind of obvious when
someone reads the rest of your resume
right like they'll read your skills and
Technologies and they'll go look at your
projects and they'll see oh this
person's like all their projects are in
Python we should assume that Python's
what they're most familiar with like
that's good enough um you don't need to
like explicitly say it it's also one of
those things that just will get cleared
up either in a phone screen or in the
interview um so just just just don't do
the quantifying thing it's it's not
worth the time in it in the worst case
it makes you look a little silly now
this section is also one of the sections
that's most easy to customize
and what I mean by that is if you're
applying to both Python and go positions
it's pretty easy to have a version of
this section that's for your python jobs
and a version of the section that's for
your go jobs right you're going to
emphasize different Technologies and
skills in either copy of the resume
these are keywords if you're applying to
large companies it's very likely that
they have an automated ATS or HR like
like non-technical HR people or
recruiters scanning your resume and
they've just been told hey we need
someone that's done go Docker postgress
right if it doesn't have those three
things throw the resume away right so it
is important to list everything that
you're familiar with um but because
those lists can get so long you can kind
of tailor this fairly easily to the
different jobs that you're applying for
now let's talk a little more
specifically about your projects this is
going to be a section of your resume
that's very similar to your
GitHub um but I I want to talk about
exactly what you should include on the
resume so first of all of course you're
going to be including the name of the
project this next part's really
important add a link to the project I
have reviewed so many resumés that have
the name of a project but there is not a
clickable link through to the GitHub
like I want to check out your project
please make it easy for me to check out
your product um a short description of
the project so this should really be
just like one or two sentences um
probably the same as the like
what or why or even just the description
on the project on GitHub right so you
don't necessarily need to write new copy
for this it should be very similar to
what exists on
GitHub um you're definitely going to
want to include the tech stack and
Technologies used in the project like
this is a good way to signal to the
person looking at your resume that you
know certain Technologies right and it's
a lot more powerful than just saying I
am a good goang developer right like no
it's much better to have have a great go
project and to list underneath I used go
and I used postgress right and I used
Goose or whatever Technologies I used
great okay um finally I want to say two
more things that I think are really
important
um two projects here is good three is
probably too many um on GitHub you know
if you have a lot of projects if you're
an experienced developer with many years
I mean you can have six you can have
eight projects on your GitHub you're
calling attention to and it's not really
a problem um but on your resume there's
not enough room for that and you really
want to kind of emphasize I would say at
most two projects on your resume um only
do three if you if you really feel
strongly about that third
one um and then finally don't be afraid
to use at least a paragraph or two for
each project so like it's okay if
there's a a decent amount of text
underneath each project eding and
description or sorry heading and
Link because especially if you're
someone with no work experience it's
like what else are you going to put on
your resume like you really want to be
spending the time kind of showing off
how great this project is so it really
is okay to have some bullet points to
have an explanation of each project like
don't shy away from that so we already
talked about this a little bit but the
work experience section of your resume
even if you haven't had a programming
job yet is still very important there's
two things you can do first you can list
previous jobs that you've had that are
not programming related and if they're
programming adjacent you can do your
best to emphasize any little bit of
coding or Ops or command line like
anything that you did that's remotely
related to programming like emphasize
that in the description of the job so
that's number one but number two is if
you don't if you don't have any
programming experience you can always go
get some experience without having to
get hired let me show you what I mean
I've got a clip from Bill Kennedy the
founder of ardan labs or one of the
founders of ardan labs um and he was on
my podcast back in banter and he's going
to talk a little bit about how you can
do
this so this is what I would say and I
talked to my wife about this as
well she's in a place right now where
because there's so many people looking
for work and the economy is falling
apart and there's openings but the 5,000
hour people are getting them right now
because there's just too many of them um
what do you do do you know how many
nonprofits there are right now that need
software development I mean you're
looking for something to problem to
solve go knock on a local
nonprofit and tell ask them what
technology problems do you have right
now maybe you'll get lucky and they need
some sort of website that could Le
leverage some backend
apis why not work on that there's no
stress you ain't getting paid there's no
timetable you now have a problem that
you have to solve so you get to learn
without any stress and you're helping
the community out at the same time and
then on your resume I'll show you how to
make that look like you were working at
a job because you technically were even
though you weren't getting paid but we
don't put salaries on resumés do we so
now under experience you are working
with 501c3 nonprofit blank building
software this wasn't school it wasn't
education it was a job it happened to be
pro bono but who cares and so this is
what I'm going to say to you okay if you
have that time and you're looking for a
project there are a ton of nonprofit
organizations all over the place that
would love your help and maybe part of
that project isn't Fun and fancy for you
maybe there's a browser front end piece
to it well then get your friend who
loves front end to do that and let them
learn how to work and get together as a
team and you do all the backend apis and
the database stuff and and who imagine
if everybody did that how much better
the world would be so I think this is
really great advice what employers are
looking for in your experience section
isn't really that you were paid to do
work it's that you did work that was
useful to someone right so even if you
work for a nonprofit pro bono right
you're not getting paid like Bill said
uh or if you contribute to a larger
open- source project and those
contributions actually get merged and
used you weren't paid but I don't
believe I certainly wouldn't as a hiring
manager have any problem with you
including that in your work experience
section as long as you're super clear
about who you were doing the work for
right you want to be clear this was work
for a nonprofit 501c3 or this was work
for this open source project you don't
need to list your salary right like Bill
said you don't have to put that it was
pro bono or for free work that's not a
question that comes up just put who you
did the work for and what impact it had
my philosophy around this kind of stuff
is of course you always want to be
telling the truth you never want to be
caught in a lie and that means that you
shouldn't ever lie about this kind of
stuff but at the same time it's all
about putting your best foot forward and
presenting yourself in the best possible
light right you don't need to draw
attention to the things that some
employers might view as weaknesses right
why would you do that on the same token
you don't want to Omit anything that
employer might see as a strength so show
off your
strengths don't bring attention to your
weaknesses don't lie be transparent and
you can make a a resume that otherwise
looked really unimpressive actually look
like top of the pack now let's talk
about applying to jobs right everything
we've done up to this point has just
been getting us ready to apply for jobs
we're just getting profiles ready we're
building a resume we want to be in a
really great spot so that once we start
applying for jobs everything that we do
is as effective as it can be right you
put in the work up front and now you can
just churn out a bunch of applications
and they'll be a lot more effective than
if you didn't go optimize all of those
things first so the first thing I want
to talk about is like let's set a weekly
goal right right now and just go do it
and and what I mean is first of all
sometimes people try to apply to way too
many jobs right you hit the ground
running for a day or two you apply to a
hundred jobs you don't get any call
backs and you get discouraged right like
you can get burnt out pretty easily I
recommend trying to find a healthy Pace
right maybe 20 25 jobs um something like
that that you can apply to again I don't
know three four jobs a day try to hit
that 25 jobs a week goal or whatever
kind of goal you set um but you
shouldn't be spending more than like an
hour a day on this right at most like
two hours because keep in mind you still
want to be spending time learning
building and doing some of the other
activities like networking and warm
introductions that we'll talk about in a
later chapter and then just don't wait I
hear so many students kind of get to
this point in their career journey and
the impostor syndrome hits like am I
really ready to apply for jobs no no no
I'm G to spend a little bit more time
tweaking my resume I'm G to spend
another week on my project it's like
just start applying like I've almost
never seen someone start applying too
soon because all that happens is that
you get rejected and in some cases you
get feedback about that rejection right
like oh your project wasn't impressive
enough for us or oh we're looking for
this keyword on the resume and you had
that keyword you don't always get
feedback but sometimes times you do
especially if you ask for it but you
always get the feedback of accepted or
rejected right and so I would just start
that process sooner than later okay so
the natural question is where should I
apply right now there are the obvious
places of course I'm not going to spend
a lot of time but like Indie LinkedIn
glass door angelist uh these are places
that you should be spending some time
applying um the problem with these
places though is that while yes all of
the jobs are there like there
many many thousands millions of jobs
hosted on those platforms um there's
also all the competition right so you're
going to want to spend some time there
but you don't want to spend all your
time there um
because everyone in the world is
applying to the top 50 jobs that show up
when you type backend developer on
LinkedIn right like everyone is applying
to those um it doesn't mean you can't
apply to those you can right LinkedIn
has a really great easy apply apply
button but just remember that linkedin's
easy apply button it's really convenient
you don't need to fill out a whole
application all you have to do is click
the button but that's all anyone has to
do so those job postings are going to
have much higher application rates
because there's thousands of people on
their phones scrolling for jobs on
LinkedIn clicking the easy apply button
right so we're going to talk about in
addition to spending some time on the
large platforms we're going to talk
about some other plac that you could
also be applying um places where the
competition will be much lower and
you'll have a much greater chance of
standing out so the first one that like
crazily gets overlooked is your local
area right so in 2020 and 2021 obviously
the entire world went remote especially
in technology um but it's 2022 or rather
it's it's been rough in 2022 and 2023
for the job market and the culture of
remote only
has shifted back to there being a lot
more on-site jobs so just don't forget
that there are a lot of on-site jobs and
when you limit yourself to remote only
um you are playing on hard mode in the
sense that you're you're competing with
the whole world at that point um when
you when you apply to jobs that are in
your local area you're only competing
against the other candidates in your
local area so um there are a few great
advantages right the candidate pool is
much smaller um you can meet the folks
that work at the company that you want
to apply at you can meet them in person
right you can maybe even just ask them
to meet you for coffee it doesn't even
have to be the hiring manager it could
just be somebody that works at the
company um you can get a sense of the
company culture just by visiting the
office right and if you do get the job
you'll be able to work with your
co-workers and mentors in person which
means you'll learn faster which is
actually a huge Advantage um you can
have a remote first job I'm not saying
you shouldn't consider it but there are
some distinct advantages to being in
office with other Developers especially
in the first year of your career there's
something about being able to just like
spin around in your chair and chat with
somebody about a technical problem that
you just don't get over slack while
we're talking about local jobs I want to
play a clip that a friend of mine Kent c
dods um the author of Epic web.dev and
epic react um he put together it's a
story of his from when he was applying
when he was right out of college and how
actually showing up physically at the
office made a huge imp
and actually got him
hired hi my name is Kent C dods and I
build educational material for people
just like you on Epic web.dev to teach
people how to build full stack
applications I want to tell you about
how I got my first job in this industry
so I was going to school and I had
part-time jobs uh while I was in school
that were in the industry and that was
cool but uh I noticed all of my friends
were starting to get their full-time job
offers and I was really nervous about
that I was interning at working
part-time at a company called Domo um
and I took a break from them to go
intern at another place over the summer
and when I came back uh I was talking
before I left I told them hey I'm going
to want to come back I want to have my
job back yeah yeah that's fine uh so two
weeks before I come back and calling
them and saying hey I'm going to come
back and I couldn't get a hold of
anybody so I'm like great that uh that's
not good I'm not going to have a job and
I have uh at this time I had a daughter
and another uh kid on the way so I'm
like oh shoot I need to be able to make
money even while I'm in school so um I
get back and I still haven't heard from
them and the Monday uh comes on the what
I thought was going to be my first day
at uh the office again and I decide just
to go um and so I just went into the the
office and I said hey I'm back and they
said oh uh we were totally not expecting
you but okay and I said you can go find
my manager and and and uh he came out in
his face like whoa what are you doing
here um and I I just thought like what's
the worst they can do just tell me to go
home I don't have a job um but that's
not what they did what they did was they
like okay come on back we'll find you a
computer we'll get you working and I uh
I got my job back but again this was
just an internship all my friends were
getting their full-time uh jobs
postgraduation and everything so I was a
little bit nervous uh about that and
they weren't interested in giving me a
full-time offer uh contingent on my
graduation or whatever they just like
when you graduate maybe we will have
something for you so uh we had these
hack knite projects every couple of
weeks um we would do these hack kns and
I would participate in those because
they were fun and I built something that
was pretty cool uh cool enough that my
cooworker decided the CEO should see it
um and so uh this was late in the
evening like 11:30 uh the CEO is still
at the company it's a startup and he
didn't have work life balance I don't
know um but he was there and so he comes
over and I fumble through my
presentation and I say yeah this this is
what I did it's kind of cool and Merrick
Christensen the the one who brought the
CEO over said yeah Josh like this is
super cool this guy he's just an intern
like he's only working part-time and I
said yeah and Josh was like oh yeah
that's cool and I said yeah actually um
if you give me an offer right now I'll
accept it a little bit bold there and
everybody there were a bunch of people
around watching and they were pretty
surprised that it's takes such a bold
move to uh talk that way to the CEO um
but Josh liked that I guess and he slid
a piece of paper with a pen over to me
and said go ahead and write down your
number and I said well uh okay I hadn't
actually thought about what my number
was I wrote something down that I
thought was good and uh he called up the
HR uh director and said hey can I hire
this kid and I they were like yeah I
guess so so that's how I got my first
job um and so hopefully that is uh you
can take a couple
of like lessons out of that like be bold
and you know not overbearing I wasn't
like a jerk about anything or whatever I
wasn't annoying or anything but I I
showed up um and I was ready to do the
work uh I put in good work I worked hard
and uh delivered really good stuff uh
and I made certain that the right people
knew about the work that I was doing uh
and the opportunities that they could
have to work with me so um I hope that
is helpful to you in some way that's how
I got my first full-time job out of
graduating out of University and good
luck on your own Journey see you the
next place I'd really encourage you to
look is on compan websites so if you
know the companies in your area or if
you know the companies that just exist
out in the world that are hiring remote
and you like those companies you can go
straight to their careers page like just
Google the name of the company and
careers and you'll almost certainly find
their careers page page um the nice
thing about going straight to the
website is a lot of times those
applicants are fast-tracked because
they're not going through like layers
and layers of HR software sometimes
there's even just an email address for
you to submit a resume to right so it's
a way to kind of take a side door that
not everyone's taking right most people
are not going straight to the companies
they want to work at and looking at
their careers Pages they're just
trolling job boards right so
um definitely spend some time here you
should have an idea of some of the
companies that you'd like to work out uh
to to work at it's it's worth taking the
time just to check out their careers
page if they have one the next place you
can look is in Niche job boards so
you've got the big job boards like
indeed and Linkedin but there's also
Niche job Boards out there little ones
right like remote okay Goan Cafe we work
remotely these are job boards that like
not everybody is on and so the
competition the people that are applying
for those jobs is going to be much much
lower um it's easier to to stand out um
I also want to call special attention to
Hacker News Right Hacker News is kind of
a Reddit like uh site run by Y
combinator and every month they do a
who's hiring thread they also do a they
do a who's hiring and who's looking for
work and it's kind of this old
intimidating like Texton
website but it's a really great place to
go and hang out and meet some folks and
apply to jobs like the old fash way
right so a great way to kind of again
we're looking for ways that we can take
the side door so that we're not
competing against you know a thousand
people all clicking the easy apply
button on LinkedIn so definitely check
that out and if you want this little
list of n JW boards you can come to boot
dodev and go to Chapter 6 Lesson two and
I've got links to all of them
um this is just a few examples that came
to my mind there are a lot of these um
in fact uh there's also a lot of like
local slack and Discord communities that
will just have a jobs Channel and like
local companies will post in the jobs
channel one more point is that non-te
companies do hire developers and frankly
I started really at a non-te company a
nons software company right I was
working as a developer on like internal
tooling it was more of a hardware
company and that's a pretty common story
for people just getting into development
so don't overlook the fact fact that
there might be companies in your local
area that need developers but they don't
advertise their jobs in all the same
sexy ways that like Venture Capital
backed startups do right um I mean we
looked at Danny Thompson's profile he's
working at AutoZone right like that's
not a traditional tech company and yet
he's killing it there so make sure
you're keeping an open minds to all of
the opportunities that might be out
there now let's take a second and talk
about recruiters recruiters can be
helpful but they can also be a gigantic
waste of time and you don't want that to
happen let me explain recruiters make
money on commissions generally speaking
so when they help a candidate land a job
or more specifically they're hired by
the company so when they help a company
find a candidate that's when they get
paid and to be perfectly blunt there is
not a lot of money if any in sourcing
entrylevel developers so if you an
entrylevel developer it's unlikely that
recruiter will be useful to you now
there are some exceptions if you want to
go work at Fang companies like big tech
companies they often have internal
recruiters that we are trying to find
like upand cominging Talent right um a
lot of times they Source out of
universities um or maybe they're doing
sourcing on like big open source
projects or at large hackathons um in
those cases like yes or an internal
recruiter will probably be useful to you
as an entry-level candidate but
recruiters that work for like third-
party uh recruiting agencies are going
to be unlikely to be helpful to you
because they're not going to be making
money on those transactions to be
perfectly Frank so I'm not saying you
should ignore every recruiter and Mark
all of their messages as spam when they
do reach out to you but I I just want
you to be wary of your time because what
recruiters do is they spray out messages
to a ton of people either via DM on
LinkedIn for example or via email and
they're they're trying to contact tons
and tons of people and then they're kind
of just like putting the time on the
people that they're contacting to get
back in touch with them if they're a
good fit so you don't want to spend a
lot of time like Gathering you know your
resume and your links and answering the
recruiter's questions if it's unlikely
that you're going to get the job in the
end so just just be wise about it my
recommendation is interact with some of
the recruiters you can kind of see how
the game is played but just be wary and
don't try to waste uh too much of your
time with them especially if you're an
entry level candidate once you do have
more experience right once you have a
couple of years of experience you're
applying to like a mid-level or senior
role recruiters actually can be
extremely helpful because they're highly
incentivized to get you placed in that
role and they can make as much as like
20% 30% of your yearly salary um so it
does get it does get it does get to the
point where they are actually very
useful to you um but if your entry level
just be careful it's time to talk about
the disgusting corporate word that is
networking so networking is a long-term
play I want to like get this out there
you really want to start networking
early um ideally even when you're still
just learning to code um if you're
watching this video um you probably are
more towards the kind of I don't want to
say end of your Learning Journey because
there there is no end that's the wrong
way to say it but you know you've been
learning for a while I guess is the way
I'd put it and now you're looking for
work um networking is the ultimate side
door right so we talked about how
there's some side doors when you're
applying to jobs like instead of going
through the front door which is like
LinkedIn easy apply we're going to go
find Niche job boards or apply directly
on Hacker News threads or company's
careers Pages or walking into the office
right those are some side doors but the
ultimate side
door is networking it's making friends
who have jobs in the industry and then
eventually those friends might stick
their neck out for you right and let you
know about an opportunity or even if
it's not sticking their neck out for you
it can be as simple as giving you a warm
introduction to a hiring manager so let
me give you some
examples let me Zoom this in so do not
cold DM people asking them if they have
work for you that is not networking I've
met lots of people who think this is
networking this is not networking right
this is just spamming DMS and it's not
not helpful and I've never seen it work
so probably don't do that um don't join
Discord servers and spam spam the jobs
Channel right now that doesn't mean that
the jobs channel is not useful to you it
can be but you probably want to either a
look through the jobs channel for open
positions and then go apply to them or B
hang out in that Discord for a while and
make some genuine friends in there right
become a regular become a trusted member
of the community and over time you'll be
more likely to be considered um by the
hiring managers that are also hanging
out there they're not going to do you
any special favors if they just met you
that's why I say networking is a long
game it's building up a bunch of real
friendships and real relationships
within the tech community and then
eventually those relationships will just
naturally become useful to you it's not
about exploiting those relationships
it's just you you build them up and you
get sort of this mutually beneficial
relationship between you and whoever you
become friends with so another one is do
not show up at meetups and hand out
business cards right when you attend
meetups which we'll talk about more in
just a second like you should be
spending your time there just getting to
know people right getting to know people
making friends you want to show up
consistently don't expect to like be
everyone's best friend after the first
Meetup every time you go you can sit by
somebody different and talk to them um
but you don't need to just show up and
hand out business cards um do engage in
conversations with folks on Twitter
LinkedIn Discord Etc about something
they posted about right so when somebody
posts on one of these social platforms
or like hangout servers or communities
right like Discord or slack um they're
posting about what they're interested in
it's like engage with what they're
already interested in that's like one of
the best ways to make friends again like
I can't I I don't want to like make a
course on this cuz it's just s such
basic stuff
um but for some reason you know we we
struggle with it um help people out when
they ask for help online right so a lot
of kind of new people to the idea of
networking just reach out and ask for
help do you have work for me will you be
my mentor can you help me with this
problem I'm having you're going to make
good friends and build strong
relationships much faster if you just do
the opposite right if you're the helpful
one
right everyone wants to help someone
who's helped them in the past so if
you're a very helpful person online that
will come back to you in the long run
I'm going to keep saying it but
networking is a long
game um and then do go to meetups and
talk to people about the talk that was
just given right so meetups are just a
place to hang out talk about technology
if you do that if you do it consistently
you will build a
network you you it's it's practically
impossible to go to a Meetup
and hang around after the talk and talk
to a few people if you do that for six
months it's basically impossible to not
build a little Network so just just keep
that in mind there is a Time Factor
that's important on that note I had
Mariah Peterson on the backend banter
podcast and she runs several meetups and
even organizes a conference and she
talks about how much meetups can help
you in your first job search so let's
cut to that
clip
um I used to pre pandemic and a little
bit during the pandemic it it got really
hard during the pandemic but pre
pandemic I would go to a boot camp every
three months and I would talk to their
cohorts and I'd
say and all I did was talk about going
to meetups I like there were probably at
10 at least 30 to 40 local meetups in
Utah at the time and I said if you want
a job you go to these meetups and it's
not to say hey I'm looking for a job
it's because that way you meet the
people who are hiring the people that go
to these jobs are hiring managers we
used to get a lot more recruiters than
we do now but they they they want to
refer you your friends want to refer you
to jobs and the only way to make friends
is to go to meetups and then it's so
natural and easy to socialize with
people who have the same interests as
you like you can go to a Meetup and be
like whoa you like talk about weird
things you'll be like oh you also use a
Linux laptop instead of a Mac or oh you
like Macs or oh I've never thought about
building a video game in go I love it
that was one of our talks was somebody
wrote a video game in go a Game Boy
Advance game that you could run on
emulators and it was so cool and all of
the Nerds that play video games now want
to do that or talk about your like like
there there are so many nerds with so
many interests I've had a talk of
somebody who like yeah I wrote a go
library to edit my images for me so they
would do SVG edits on image editing the
SVG Library great so you like visual
input like there's there's so many
facets and interests and once you make
those people with similar interests
you'll never have to look for a job like
my I I my I after my first job I got my
second job from a Meetup I got my third
job because I host a
conference and the people recognized my
conference I got my most recent job
because of meetups because I go to so
many PE meetups and people know who I am
like and I'm not saying you have to run
them I love when people who don't have
experience speak um because it's new
like I love when people share what they
do I do not care how professional it is
I just want to see your demo like that's
all I want to see I want to see you run
that code you worked on so hard so I can
clap and applaud for you but like if you
want to get a job you have to find your
community I don't care if your community
is online but the best communities are
local in person uh that is my unbiased
opinion I just want to emphasize I think
that going to local meetups is one of
the best long-term things that you can
do to make your job search easier in
other words if you're just now getting
started on your job search and you start
going to a Meetup once a week right so
that would mean you'd probably need to
find four different meetups in your
local area to be able to go once a week
because they usually meet on like a
monthly basis but if you can find four
meetups that sound interesting to you
and go to one every single week after
six months you'll have met so many
people in the industry right if you
don't take advantage of this it's it's
look it's like the old saying looking a
gift horse in the mouth like I would I
would be suspicious of whether or not
you're actually taking your job search
seriously right I I get that there are
some circumstances that make it imp
possible if you live really far away
from any sort of city that has meetups
right or if for whatever reason maybe
you work a job that's always in the
evening so you're not able to make it so
I get it there are some circumstances
where you can't but if you can it is so
helpful please try to find meetups and
please try to attend them it won't get
you a job on week one but it's very
likely to help you out over the long
term Quincy Larsson the founder of free
code Camp which is of course massive
amazing resource for learning to code
for free um also of course the channel
That this course is hosted on on YouTube
um Quincy published a book recently
called how to learn to code and get a
developer job now obviously this course
is not about how to learn to code um but
it is about how to get a developer job
so I would be super remiss if I did not
mention this book first of all the
book's available for free online um and
if you want to read it I'm going to drop
a description uh a link in the
description below um but what I'm also
going to do is read you a quick excerpt
from the book and I got Quincy's
permission to do this so I mean I guess
it's available for free online so uh but
we talked about it
okay the story
starts how did a teacher in his 30s get
his first developer job I had just
finished a long day of learning at the
Santa Barbara downtown library sipping
tea and building projects the best thing
about living in California is the
weather we joke that when you rented an
exorbitantly priced one-bedroom
apartment in the suburbs you were not
paying for the inside you were paying
for the outside my goal was to spend as
little time in that cramped 100-year-old
rat trap as necessary and to spend the
rest of it walking around the town it
was a beautiful Wednesday evening I
still had two more days to prepare for
that week's hack hackathon and my brain
was completely fried from the day of
coding my wife was working late so I
checked my calendar to find something to
do so first of all I understand that
like depending on where you live there
will be more or less Tech events um if
you have hackathons in your area um
often times hackathons are happening at
like local colleges or boot camps and
very often you don't need to be a
student to go um so just just like do
your research and and find them because
hackathons are a great way to get
practice they're super fun and if you
win there's usually a few prizes but
even better is that you can put on your
resume that you want a hackathon which
is which is awesome okay so uh on the
first Monday of each month I would map
out all of that month's upcoming Tech
events around Southern California so I'd
always have a tech event to attend if I
had the energy again this is this is
just like great advice right look look
on meetup.com do your research find all
the tech events and if you have time in
the evenings you should be going um your
your network will expand you'll learn a
ton there's just really really no reason
not to do it um obviously Quincy was in
California that's a great place to be uh
for Tech but um even even smaller towns
have meetups even if even if they're
small ah tonight is the Santa barara
Ruby on Rails meet up and I had already
rsvpd I didn't know a lot about Ruby on
Rails but I completed a few small
projects with it I was much more of a
JavaScript and python developer but I
figured what the heck I need to keep up
my momentum with building my network and
the venue was just a few blocks away I
walked in and it was just a few devs
sitting around a table chatting it
quickly became clear that they all
worked together at a local startup
maintaining a large Ruby on Rails code
base most of them had been working there
for several years now at this point I'd
spent the past year building my skills
my Network my reputation so I was able
to hold my own during the conversation
but I also had a feel for the limits of
my ability so I stayed modest
understated the way I'd seen so many
other successful developers maneuver a
conversation at Tech events it became
clear that one of the developers at the
table was the director of engineering
and he reported directly to the CTO this
is another important Point um when I go
to our local go Meetup or our local rust
Meetup here in Utah um there's like 10
to 20 people and like half of them are
managers or SE level technology
Executives so like you get direct access
to some of the most influential people
in the area typically when you go to a
tech event obviously that's not true of
every area um but it's just like I
cannot emphasize enough how important it
is that you take advantage of meetups if
they're available in your area um and
one more thing I'll mention is if you
live far away from somewhere where there
are me UPS like say you live you know an
hour outside of a city that has several
events um maybe you don't go every week
but maybe you go once a month and make
the commute right it really could be
worth it for your career anyways
something to think
about and it became clear they were
looking to hire Ruby on Rails developers
I was candid about my background and my
abilities my background is in adult
education teaching English and running
schools I just started to learn to code
about a year ago but the man was
surprisingly unfazed well if you want to
come in for an interview we can see
whether you'd be a good fit for the team
that night I walked home feeling an
electricity it was much more dread than
excitement I felt nowhere near ready and
I wasn't even looking for a job I was
just living off of my savings learning
to code full-time with health insurance
through my wife's job I was a compulsive
saver people would give me a hard time
about it I would change my own oil cut
my own hair and even cook my own rice at
home when we ordered takeout just to
save a few bucks over the decade that
I'd worked as a teacher I'd managed to
save nearly a quarter of my after tax
earnings and I would buy old video games
on Craigslist and flip them on eBay that
may sound silly but it was a substantial
source of income for me what what were
were we saving all this for we weren't
sure maybe to buy a house in California
at some point in the future but it did
but it meant that that I did not have to
hustle to get a job I knew I was in a
privileged position and I tried to make
the most of it by learning more every
day there are a lot of strategies when
you're learning to code right Quincy's
story he was learning to code for about
a year and he was able to do it
full-time because he'd been so
aggressive with his savings that's
certainly one way to do it um another
way to do it obviously is to learn in
your off time I've seen successful cases
um or I should say I've seen examples of
success doing it both ways really just
do what works best for you um but I
think a year of of learning and building
is you should plan on at least a year of
learning and building no matter what you
end up doing so if you're going to quit
your job you really want in my opinion
at least 12 R months of Runway before
you're expecting yourself to get that
full-time developer job this is just
this is just my perception um and same
thing if you're doing like an online
course like boot Dev on the side uh you
should expect that you'll be doing it
nights and weekends for probably at
least a year like this is not something
that happens overnight and frankly
anyone that's selling courses or boot
camps and promising jobs in 12 weeks I'd
be highly skeptical of that um this is a
this is a wide and a deep profession uh
there's a lot to learn and doing it in
12 weeks is nearly
impossible okay um where were we
at so in short I didn't think I was
ready for my first developer job and I
was worried that if they hired me it
would be a big mistake they would
realize how inexperienced I was fire me
and then I'd have to explain that
failure during future job interviews of
course I now know I was looking at this
opportunity the wrong way but let me
finish the story when I scheduled my job
interview they asked me for a resume I
wasn't sure what to do so I left all my
professional experience there all the
schools I'd worked for over the years I
left off my time running the drive-thru
a Taco Bell though of course none of my
work experience had anything to do with
coding but what was I supposed to do
hand them a blank sheet of paper well I
did have an online portfolio of projects
i' built and most importantly I had a
list of all the hackathons I'd won or
placed at so I included those I spent
the final hours before the interview
revisiting all the Ruby on Rails
tutorials I've used over the past year
to refresh my memory and then I put on
my hoodie jeans and backpack and walked
over to the office the office manager
was a nice lady who took me back to the
developer Bullpen and introduced me to
their small team of devs there were
maybe a dozen of them mostly dressed in
jeans and hoodies aged from early 20s to
late 40s uh two of them were women I
took turns navigating the tangle of
desks and cables shaking hands with each
of them and introducing myself this is
where all my experience as a classroom
teacher memorizing student names came in
handy I was able to remember all of
their names so that later in the day
when I left I could follow up with each
of them great meeting you name I'd be
excited to work alongside you this is a
big
deal uh this is like soft skills do
matter when someone tells you their name
at an interview try to remember it and
try to use it later it just it just goes
a long way and I know it's not like
technical advice on how to nail the
technical part of the interview but I I
can't stress enough how important the
soft skills
are first I met with the director of
engineering we went into a small office
and closed the door a whiteboard on the
wall was covered in sketches of unified
modeling language uml diagrams a rainbow
of dry erase marker laid out the
relationships between various servers
and Services I kept glancing at the
Whiteboard fearing that he'd send me
over to it to solve some coding problems
and demonstrate my skills maybe the
famous fizzbuzz problem maybe he'd want
me to invert a binary tree but he never
even mentioned the Whiteboard he just
sat there looking intensely at me the
whole time they were a company of about
50 employees with lots of venture
capital funding and thousands of paying
customers mostly small businesses they
prided themselves on being pragmatic at
no point did they inquire about what I
studied at school or what kind of work I
did in the past all they cared about
was look I know you can code he said
you've been coding this whole time
winning hackathons I checked out your
portfolio projects the code quality was
okay for someone who's new to coding so
for me the real question is can you
learn how we do things here can you work
with the other devs on the team and most
critically can you get things
done boot Dev right now has six
employees these are the exact same
questions that are going through my mind
when I'm hiring right like I don't have
the luxury to care I don't have the
luxury to care about your degree I don't
have the luxury to care about if you can
solve hard lead code problems at my
stage of company right boot Dev is not
as big as as this company it sounds like
they've got 50 employees but the idea is
similar often times at these small
companies we're asking very basic
questions about can you just ship
working code can you do it quickly and
can you learn the stuff that we're using
can you follow our processes right I
gulped leaned forward mustered all the
confidence I could yes I believe I
can confidence is good it's good he said
good good okay wait in the F restaurant
downstairs the CTO should be down there
in a minute so I talked with the CTO
over noodles mostly listened I learned
that people project intelligence I I
learned that people project intelligence
onto quiet people listening intently not
only helps you get smarter it even makes
you look smarter this is interesting and
this is something I struggle with I like
to talk um but being a good listener and
asking the right questions at the right
moment I I completely agree with Quincy
here uh it does make you look smarter
the approach worked the meeting lasted
in about an hour the noodles were tasty
I learned a lot about the company
history and the near-term goals the CTO
said okay go back up and talk with the
director of engineering and I did and he
offered me a job now I want to emphasize
this is not how most people get their
first developer
job I get what Quincy is saying here and
who knows Quincy might even have data on
this that I'm not privy to but I've been
interviewing people on the backend Baner
podcast and I'm coming to believe more
and more that weird stories like this
are actually how most people get their
first job and that the traditional
hiring cycle actually is is more common
for second third and fourth jobs but
that's just that's just been my uh my
perception um from from the few
anecdotes that I have uh you know
insight
into now you're probably thinking gee
here Quincy is forced gumping his way
into developer job that he wasn't even
looking for if only we could all be so
lucky and that's certainly what it felt
like for me at the time but in the next
section I'm going to explore the
relationship between employers and
developers and how me Landing that job
was less about my skills as an
interviewee and more about the year of
coding networking and reputation
building that preceded it this wasn't a
cushy job at a big tech company with all
the compensation benefits and Company
bowling alleys it was a contractor role
that paid about the same as I was making
as a teacher but it was a developer job
a company was paying me to write code I
was now a professional developer again
if you're interested in the rest of the
story and want to read the full book
description uh Link in the description
below definitely go check it out this is
is really important this wasn't a cushy
job at a big tech company with all the
compensation benefits and Company
bowling alleys it was a contractor role
that paid about the same as I was making
as a
teacher I was making less than a teacher
in my very first developer role but
getting a developer job and being paid
to write code is like this binary thing
you go from never having any developer
job to having a developer job forget
what the developer job is for a second
but just having one is this huge switch
in your life and going from a mediocre
developer job to a great developer job
is much easier once you have that year
of experience on your resume now virtual
meetups are also a thing um and they are
definitely worth your time if you can't
do in-person meetups it's it's kind of
going to be one of those things that's
better than nothing the thing that I
found with virtual meetups is they're
usually more about the talks and less
about the networking just because often
it's a lot harder to like do networking
like just sit and chat with somebody
over Zoom um but if it's all you've got
it's it's worth at least trying out okay
so next I want to spend some time on
online communities so we've talked about
how you know you can go find slack
communities and Discord communities and
like find jobs there um but I want to
talk about like the networking that you
can do in an online community so for
example um here I've linked the the boot
Dev Discord that is an online community
there's also a free code Camp Discord
that is an online community um there's a
golang slack like an official slack for
the entire go programming language and
there's also a Discord for the Python
programming language it's very large
right there's tons of these communities
on slack and Discord that are
essentially just instant messaging
platforms um there's a right way and a
wrong way to network in these
communities right the wrong way is
showing up out of the blue and asking
for favors like don't do that but
similar to meetups if you hang out in
one or two or I would say at most three
because you probably won't have time for
more than three um you hang out
consistently in these in these
communities and become known as a
regular that's a pretty powerful thing
it's almost as good probably not as good
but almost as good as being known as a
regular in a physical Meetup right
occasionally people come into the
community and they're hiring or
occasionally someone else in the
community's company is hiring ing right
and if you're good friends with them
because you chat with them daily in
Discord like you're much more likely to
be considered for one of those
opportunities right and once you get to
know all of these people they won't be
bothered when you make a few posts about
how you're looking for work right maybe
you turn it into a story so it doesn't
just look like an advertisement for the
fact that you're looking for work right
maybe it's hey I've been looking for a
job these are the places I've applied
these are the places where I found more
luck or could you review my resume right
like there's ways to share the fact that
you're looking for work that's more of
like a feedback learning driven approach
than just an advertisement approach
right a asking for feedback on a project
or on a resume or on your LinkedIn
profile those are great ways to like let
your friends in the community know that
you're looking for work and again if
they like you which is something that
you can't fake you just have to be
likable right and hang out in the places
and build real relationships but if they
like you and they know you're looking
for work and they have an opportunity
they might share it with you right
several of the jobs that I've um had in
the latter half of my career have been
due to my network so I'm going to
recommend three types of communities
that you'll want to think about spending
a good amount of time in the first is
either the boot Dev Discord or the free
code Camp Discord so these are like
discords that are dedicated to learning
code um these are not places to network
uh for jobs right they are places to
network for learning learning to code
but not for jobs um so that's like place
number one um the other two places are
going to be more useful for jobs so the
first is like official Tech Community
communities I don't know how else to say
that but like like the python Discord or
the go Discord right hanging out in
there that can be a great place to over
time be exposed to Opportunities the
second one is actually
local communities on slacker Discord so
like virtual versions of local
communities for example here in Utah
there is a slack called Forge Forge Utah
um it's a fantastic slack for the Utah
area that's all about like Tech and
business in Utah so hanging out on there
making friends there is a great way to
get exposure to like all the new jobs
that are getting posted as they get
posted a lot of times when a company
posts a new job on a job board they'll
immediately post it in these slacks and
kind of FastTrack those people that are
applying through the slack because they'
found that just you know higher quality
candidates tend to hang out in there so
um local area and like Tech project
communities are great places to be now
I'd be remiss if I didn't at least
mention social media um some people have
a lot of success on social media right
um You can definitely think of some tech
fluenc for example who probably get lots
and lots of job offers because they have
a lot of followers on Twitter or YouTube
or LinkedIn or
wherever in my experience those those
things tend to follow
like a distribution curve that's it's
not looking good in the average case I
guess is what I would say if you do
really well on social media right if you
have tens of thousands of followers then
a platform like Twitter might be a great
place to advertise that you're looking
for work right you have 10,000 100 ,000
followers like you can probably find
work on Twitter if you have a couple
hundred followers or less it is
extremely unlikely that you will find
work by making posts on Twitter so I
would say in the average case social
media is just going to be a waste of
time there are
exceptions um and if you have a decent
following or you know good engagement on
those platforms then then maybe it'll
work out for you but I would just I just
want to caution and say like if you
notice you're spending a lot of time on
social media and you're not getting any
bites it's probably not the best place
right in-person meetups online
communities um Niche job boards those
are the places that you're going to get
better Returns on the time that you
invest now before we move on from the
networking chapter I want to play you
one more clip from the backend Baner
podcast I had Don the developer on the
Pod and he talks about how there are
good ways to ask for warm intros and
there are good ways to DM someone asking
them about a potential job or what it's
like working in a company and there are
bad ways so let's cut to this clip and
he'll tell us a little bit about kind of
the pros and cons or what I what what I
guess I guess I should say are the good
strategies and the bad strategies for
reaching out to
people
yeah
um this one could be a little bit more
complex I think the default answer is
like networking is king for a lot of
people but this one has Nuance as well
you can submit a templated
DM that like to you know HR and a lot of
people like try to connect with uh let
me give this example
so when I was uh a software engineer it
was my second company or a second dead
position I would have people reach out
that obviously wanted to work at that
company they you know had been given the
advice to just reach out to software
engineer and have coffee and I would
always make them commit to buying me a
coffee to just make sure that they were
committed I never actually make them pay
for it I just buy it when I actually got
there but I wanted to you know I I I
wanted to get past the feeling of like
okay if I'm G to give you some of my
time to talk about software engineering
like at least take it seriously and
that's what I was trying to weed out and
so like as a hiring manager you probably
have to do that a lot but there were
different Engineers that were very
upfront that were very honest authentic
uh very authentic and they were just
like you know I'm really interested in
your company but I also want to like
really get a feel for what it's like to
work at this company I had a bad
experience before and I honestly you
know I before I even apply I want to get
a feel for it is that okay I'll buy you
coffee and that like that's fine I love
that but people that would kind of just
like have like very lazy tiny messages
and expect me to like take my lunch and
have coffee like I I would actually take
part of my lunch as a developer and go
have coffee with them and they wouldn't
even like be willing to pay for the
coffee again I never made them pay but
like they weren't really committed they
it felt like they did that for 50
different companies I'm like I'm not
gonna waste my time with you like this
actually feels crappy that you're doing
this so a lot of people have this
misconception like reaching out to the
engineering team or reaching out to HR
you always have to do it not necessarily
if you're going to do it with that kind
of strategy if you want to do it like I
think showing interest genuine interest
when you're doing the cold application
approach to then reach out to HR and say
hey just want to let you know I'm
actually really excited about this
position I love it for these reasons um
um I just want to let you know I did
submit my resume and I am still
interested right just something casual
you could word it a little bit different
that can make your cold approach a
little bit more
effective but
ideally the other approach and I you got
to dedicate a little bit of time to this
I don't think you have to dedicate like
4 hours every day to this but like go to
a Meetup participate in a hackathon get
involved with the developer Community
meet other developers not as a Salesman
saying hey can you get me a job don't
ask for that value immediately with that
person just treat it like any other
interaction provide that value up front
have a casual conversation make it fun
to talk to you um and just like you know
ask what they're doing like genuinely be
interested in what they're doing if you
do that an indirect effect is usually
people want to hear what you're doing
they want to hear you know what you're
going for but a lot of people take this
approach and they just like act like a
Salesman they actually get a business
card which is fine but their goal is to
just give that business card out to
everyone that they're a developer and if
they're looking for a develop right so I
think how you do it you have to I I
think a very warm approach that's very
effective is to get involved with the
developer Community meet people talk to
them have an empathetic conversation
with them and I see that naturally it's
a more long-term strategy in my opinion
um but it's a that will naturally build
up your network and even if you're doing
it with other aspiring developers that
aspiring developer gets hired and the
company before they even make the public
job posting they're like hey uh they
just reach out to the team hey do you
guys know anyone that uh might be a good
fit for this right you already are
standing out among so many other cold
applications by that aspiring developer
that like you they had a good
interaction with you they kind of
whether they like hopefully they can
have a little assessment of like where
you are technically maybe they worked on
a project but still like that's a
cultural fit that's getting you in the
door and now you have that in so don't
Focus so much on like trying to meet uh
like go to networking events to meet the
right people just talk with other people
have those empathetic conversations
build those connections and just be a
human being and try to give back to the
devel developer community that
eventually gets noticed when you're
transparent enough to have all these
conversations so a natural warm approach
is very effective in the long run and it
typically can get you so many interview
at least interviews because a lot of
people just struggle getting interviews
that can get you an interview so you can
actually speak you're not just a piece
of paper and then you can warm up to
them in the interview then it's the same
approach it's just an empathetic
conversation having fun talking like
about twitch and gaming whatever you can
relate to and like what you love like
what you're passionate about with coding
and engineering and like but you got to
let that conversation flow naturally and
that warm like it's just about building
connections with those warm leads that's
effective I would argue you should
probably
spend I don't know I usually say spend
maybe
uh two to four hours per week just
really trying to get connected with
developers and
building up your network and just
creating
relationships and I don't think majority
of your time should be spent towards
Project work hands down just really
building up your skills but like a
little bit of time extra and just
getting involved in the dev Community is
huge so I think that the networking the
warm leads it's a more effective
approach but it's a long-term approach
so if you're struggling you're like I
need a job right now probably should
consider picking up a part-time job or
something else get your income in order
because it's building relationships and
building that Network can take a little
bit of time it's effective but you know
if you're doing it shortterm you're
going a hard cold application approach
it's time to talk about interviews but
before we talk about interviews I want
to set the stage and talk a little bit
about how it's all just a numbers game
and once you understand that it's a lot
easier to make it about the longterm
rather than the short term and stop
yourself from getting discouraged so let
me show you what I mean let's draw a
sales pH funnel what happens with a
sales funnel is when you're a
salesperson going door Todo it's a
numbers game at the end of the day
you're going to knock on 300 doors of
those 300 doors 150 are going to answer
right so you immediately lose 150 people
in this example funnel right of those
150 people maybe only 25 talk to you for
more than 5 minutes of those 25 maybe
only 10 agree to give you a phone number
and and then of those 10 maybe only two
pick up when you call and then of those
two maybe only one buys your product
right and so with that kind of a sales
funnel you know that if you talk to 300
people you'll probably get one sale so
if you want two sales you need to talk
to 600 people right so the trick with
applications is figuring out that it's
really just a sales funnel so for
example let's say that you send out 100
applications and then of those 100
applications let's say that you hear
back from 25 of them and then of those
25 let's say that you get say 15 phone
screens okay and then of the 15 phone
screens say you get five
interviews okay now these
numbers 100 25 15 5 they might be
different for uh for you but like this
isn't too
unreasonable right getting five
interviews from 100 applications oh and
we should actually go a step further
because interviews aren't the end goal
right the end goal is to get an offer or
two let's say you get two
offers and you might not be in a place
where you actually get two offers you
might get one offer and it's just take
it or leave it if you get two offers
that's fantastic because now you can
make a choice um but you get the idea
from a 100 applications you might only
get two offers right your rate might
even be worse like who knows I I I can't
tell you for sure I believe when I went
through this process um with my first
job almost a decade ago um I believe I
sent out around 100 applications and I
did around six interviews so it actually
would have been really close to this um
I did not get two offers I got one offer
uh but uh sometimes that's just how it
is um the point though
is that after sending out 40
applications right you might only hear
back a couple of times and so my point
with this with this whole thing with
drawing out this funnel is just that you
shouldn't be
discouraged when you send 20
applications and don't hear back because
also those first 20 applications are
probably going to be the worst ones
because hopefully over time you're
honing your applications you're getting
better at that whole process right this
is this is something that as time goes
on we talked about this at the very
beginning of the course right as time
goes on you want to be getting better
and better at programming and also
better and better at applying and
interviewing right these five
interviews maybe the first four you
don't get offers from but they're great
practice right you're not going to knock
your first programming interview out of
the park unless you're a prodigy or
really lucky um practice helps so
anyways keep in mind that it's all just
a numbers game and you do have to apply
and put yourself out there a lot before
you start to see some results okay let's
talk about interview tip number
one and that is to relax and you might
be thinking is that actually useful
advice right uh it could be really
nerve-wracking to be in an interview and
I understand that just telling you to
relax probably is not doesn't seem super
use use ful um but let's talk about a
couple of things that might a help you
relax and B kind of realizes why it's so
important so the first
thing the first thing is
that you probably aren't getting the job
so this is an unfortunate reality but
when you get an interview I really don't
want you to get your hopes up to the
point of thinking wow they're
interviewing me like I'm landing this
job um it's the same thing as the funnel
going from you know 100 applications
down to five interviews five interviews
right you might get one offer right that
means four interviews where you don't
get an offer and again I don't know
exactly what your conversion rate on
interviews is going to be but it
certainly is not going to be 100% right
um even as a senior developer I'm not
getting even half I'm not even
converting half of my interviews into
offers so um understanding that you
probably aren't going to get the job and
realizing that this time you're spending
on the interview is extremely useful for
practice is kind of freeing in a way
right if you think well I only have like
a 10 to 20% chance of getting this job
anyways hopefully that kind of calms
your nerves right like get what you can
out of the process do your best ask a
ton of questions take notes and try to
figure out how you know you can use the
experience of practicing for this
interview in your next interview right
because the more interviews you do the
better an idea you have of how these
things work so you can get better and
better at it now the next one is pretty
similar but it's just this isn't a waste
of time it can be really tempting and
kind of discouraging to think to
yourself I've done seven interviews and
I haven't gotten an offer yet so I've
just wasted all of that time that's not
a very useful mindset if you go into
seven interviews completely bomb them
and at the end of the seven interviews
you have no idea what you did wrong then
yeah I guess you kind of have wasted
your time or at least you've wasted a
lot uh you've wasted a significant
portion of it you really want to once
you have seven interviews under your
belt have a really good idea of how
these interviews work and try to figure
out like what you're doing that's
working and what you're doing that's not
working and this shouldn't just inform
your job application process everything
you're doing while searching for a job
should also inform like how you're
spending your time learning more about
programming honing your craft and what
projects you're building right because
you might just find that your portfolio
projects are just a swing and a miss
they're not interesting nobody body's
asking follow-up questions in the
interviews right and so like go build a
different project right you can take
this feedback that you're getting in the
interviews and apply it
into how you're improving as a developer
the last point I want to make here is
just
that you'll get more
chances right so if you're getting
interviews through cold applications for
example um especially if they if you
live in a tech Hub right or if you're
applying for remote jobs there is an
endless amount of jobs right there's
like tens of thousands of jobs out there
that you can apply for an interview at
and so when you miss one
like the the the impact that that has on
your future ability to get jobs is
effectively
zero right it's not like there's only 10
available jobs and when you fail with
all 10 like you're done there's nothing
left that that's not how it works right
the more the more L's you take right the
more interviews that you fail at the
more practice you'll have so your your
chances should actually go up over time
and again that should just be like a
thing that makes you feel better about
the whole process and hopefully stops
you from getting discouraged when you do
get some rejections under your belt okay
the next thing I want to talk about is
having
confidence confidence in the interview
and again I understand that like this
isn't just useful advice the problem
everybody knows that you should be
confident in interviews um it's it's
it's one of those like simple things
that's actually really hard to execute
on so I totally get that but I just want
to reiterate something that I said
earlier in the course which is that I've
I've never met a true entry-level
developer so someone who has not yet had
a programming job that had too much
confidence or came across as egotistical
that definitely happens in the
programming world I've just never really
seen it at the entry level it happens at
the junior level like say once you have
six months or a year worth of
professional experience I think that
that's a little more common but what
I've seen from entry-level candidates is
that there's always this lack of
confidence there's always um a sense of
I'm going to downplay my accomplishments
this is just a toy project I just did
that I've only learned this like please
don't downplay your accomplishments with
with that kind of talk it really is your
job in the interview to talk yourself up
because nobody else is going to do that
for you now this is going to come across
as borderline
fous but the number one tip that I have
for being confident in interview is to
um just be
good be good at
coding right like
that doesn't mean you need to be a
senior developer in order to get an
entry-level position that that's not
what it means but it does mean that as
time goes on and you build more and more
projects you should be more and more
confident saying that you can solve
problems right if you've actually built
a Json API and deployed it end to endend
in the cloud with DNS and everything
then when someone asks you about that in
an interview you're just you won't have
to try you will naturally be much more
confident like oh yeah I did that thing
right oh yeah I used AWS right oh yeah I
deployed uh domain name records right oh
yeah I hooked those up to a static IP
like when you do that you get so much
more confidence just just right out of
the box so that's part of the reason why
I say as time goes on don't stop
learning and building because your
confidence will naturally grow over time
I don't have any useful like self-help
tips for faking confidence um maybe you
can read some good books that I'm not
aware of to get better at that if you
really struggle with it um but the best
thing that you can do is actually ship
code either in your own personal
projects or in open source contributions
or like we talked about earlier working
for a nonprofit or something like that
doing that will naturally give you a lot
more confidence in your abilities now
the other thing I want to say on this
point is that the reason the reason that
you should have confidence is
because people want to solve
their
problems not
yours right so we talked about how
earlier well we talked earlier in the
course about how you don't want to come
across as a charity case right that's a
negative signal um you don't want to go
around begging for jobs that's not a
good strategy um and the reason for that
is that hiring managers recruiters like
they're lives aren't easy either and
they're looking to solve their problems
right marketing departments at
successful companies are always putting
out messaging about how their company
can solve their customers's problems
it's not about what the customer can do
for the company right it's about what
the company can do for the customer and
when you're searching for a job it's not
about what the company can do for you
right by giving you a job it's about
what you can do for the company and even
more specifically it's actually about
what you can do for the person across
the table from you right it's important
to remember that companies are this like
madeup organization right they're kind
of figments of our imagination at the
end of the day really when you're on the
phone with a recruiter with an HR person
with a hiring manager they're a person
and they have
problems and if you can align everything
you're saying around how you can solve
their problems that's going to work out
much better for you so this brings me to
my next point which is just
that companies don't hire
people people hire
people this is a really important idea
to understand right companies again are
not living entities they don't have
their own intrinsic uh feelings and
motivations and emotions and needs right
people do
um people work in companies but when you
take an individual team lead right the
lead of an engineering team within a
larger
organization they are somewhat aligned
with the mission of the company right
they want the company to do well they
want the company to make money but at
the end of the day they have their own
incentives and when you're being hired
by this person you need to keep in mind
that a lot of the way that you talk
about what you can do you should be
talking about it in the sense that it
solves that person's problem
right the person who's actually going to
make the decision about hiring you it's
that person's problems that you want to
address as an employee in order to get
yourself hired so over in the text
version of this course on boot Dev I
mentioned that people hire people who
solve their problems they're not always
looking for the absolute best developer
right the most technically proficient
candidate in the pool that's not always
the person that gets the job right just
because you solved the hardest leite
code problem doesn't necessarily make
you the best candidate there's a lot um
there's a lot of stuff that goes into it
so some of the some of the points that
are very common in companies is like the
person that's hiring um the person
that's hiring you like they want their
time saved they don't want to have to
put more time into training you right so
reassuring them that you know you're a
quick learner that you're a go-getter
right that you're great at figuring
things out on your own like those kinds
of things can help alleviate concerns
that you're um that you're not going to
add to their plate but instead you're
going to take things off of their plate
right um people want to look good right
your hiring manager wants to have hiring
you be a decision that makes them look
good in the long run so again anything
you can do to prove that point um is
great they want their life to be easier
not harder um a lot of people just want
to build out their team right a lot of
managers are playing kind of internal
politics within the company and they're
just trying to grow they trying to grow
a team and have more people reporting
into them I don't think there's too much
that you can do with that information
but just kind of recognize it as a
reality um they want to deliver the
project that will secure their next
promotion um and they want you to be fun
to work with and this is actually a
really important point right so I
mentioned that it's not always the best
Elite code uh solver that gets the
job and part of it that is that it's not
always just technical proficiency right
oftentimes a manager just wants to know
that you're the kind of person that can
see a project through to completion
right if I have one person that can code
faster than another person right maybe
even code more accurately but they're
just not the kind of person that takes
projects over the Finish Line right
they're always kind of leaving it Half
Baked there's always extra testing that
needs to happen once they turn in their
work um those are things that managers
are extremely wary of like for me it's
okay if it gets done 10 to 20% slower if
it means that I don't have to be pulling
in extra resources to get something done
so there's more at play I guess is is
all I would say there and then being fun
to work with this is this is a huge one
when someone hires
you they are going to be spending a lot
of time with you right so even if you're
the best developer in the world if
you're you're kind of a jerk and you're
not fun to be around you're going to
have a much harder time Landing a job so
anything that you can do to show some
personality to show that you're fun to
show that you're happy right this goes
back to earlier when we talked about not
being a downer right you want to come
across as just a fun energetic person to
be around that actually goes a long long
way I have I have turned down candidates
solely based on the fact that I thought
myself and the rest of the team would
not enjoy working with them right that's
a totally valid reason to turn down a
candidate so just be be very aware of
that right the people assessing you are
going to have to work with you all the
time so do everything that you can to
make it look like you're going to be fun
and pleasant to work with so some of the
questions that your interviewer is
probably has in their head um are going
to be things like well I have to hold
your hand constantly right will you
learn the code base and be able to
contribute quickly right am I going to
spend 12 months getting you up to speed
or three months right do you bring new
skills to the team right do you just
know all of the same things that we know
or do you know something extra do you
have some experience in your background
that might be useful to our team and and
sometimes that's not even coding
knowledge right maybe they have a team
of three frontend developers but like I
don't know nobody's good at Photoshop
right if you know Photoshop that might
be something extra that you bring to the
table that that might help um you know
sway everything in your favor um will
you be able to quickly learn the things
you need to know but aren't yet familiar
with for this role this kind of goes
hand inhand with how quickly you'll be
able to
contribute but I can just tell you from
experience I've have I ever I don't
think I've ever hired someone where I
was confident
they were like familiar and had used
every tool that we used for that
position in other words there's always
been some amount of training that's had
to happen right like maybe I hire a
back-end developer um who's used go but
they've never used postgress with go or
they've never used our specific om right
or they're familiar with AWS we happen
to use
gcp if there's only a couple of those
things missing it's usually just fine in
fact I've like I said I've never really
had a perfect match on that level but
what that means is the interviewer is
just thinking how long is it going to
take this person to learn all of those
things and the better job you can do of
demonstrating that you're the kind of
person that can learn um the better
you'll be and just remember with
everything you do when you're applying
or this honestly applies even more
broadly to like all sales and marketing
and remember you're kind of selling your
services when you're applying for jobs
um it's much more powerful to show than
to tell so saying I'm a fast learner
it's like fine um but showing that
you're a fast learner is something
different right showing that you shipped
this really cool project in a month is a
lot more powerful than just saying oh
yeah I pick things up quickly now I know
we talked a lot about trying to have
confidence in the interview and you
should but let's break it down a little
bit because
sometimes
confidence sometimes it can be hard to
know what we should be confident about
and what we should be a little more
humble about human
humility because this directly ties into
that last point I made which was you
want to be fun to work with right and
egotistic jerks are not fun people to
work with so okay what should you be
confident about let's make a little list
here I think you should absolutely be
confident about your ability to learn
this is like universally a good thing in
a hire so you want to be able to
demonstrate that and you want to be
confident in that you do not want to
down play your ability to come up to
speed quickly on things um so absolutely
uh another thing you want to be
confident
about is
your understanding of your
projects right so you've built some
projects you really should be confident
in the fact that you built them right uh
you don't want you don't want to make it
sound like you stumbled through a
tutorial and by the way you shouldn't
have stumbled through a Tut tutorial on
these projects you should have built
them by yourself with a lot of research
um and you know doing a lot of things
from scratch
um but this is this is an area you
should be confident in and if it's if
it's not then like you should spend some
more time on your projects um something
you should be humble
about is your overall
knowledge of the
industry right and this is a this is a
key point
right because no one is expecting you to
be familiar with everything I know
sometimes it can feel that way when you
read job descriptions it's like you need
to know bash and you need to know AWS
and you need to know go and you need to
know python you need to know JavaScript
and typescript you need to know view you
need to know reacts CSS right like
there's this laundry list of items that
you're supposed to be an expert on the
reality is by the time you get to the
interview especially right once you've
gotten past HR and recruiters um
nobody's expecting you to know
everything and no one's expecting you to
be an expert on everything um especially
in an entrylevel position right you want
to show that you're proficient in a
couple of things right and that you
learned quickly that you passionate
about it that you like doing it um but
don't try to fake knowledge of
technologies that you haven't worked
with right let me give you an example
let's say in an interview that you're
asked um how much do you know about
mongod DB
you may have never even heard of mongod
DB right but let's just say that you've
used postgress and because there's DB in
the title of the name is mongod DB you
can kind of infer that it's a database
so what I would say is something like I
actually haven't had a chance to use
mongodb that's a database right which
you hear that and you might think that
sounds really dumb um but they're
probably go yeah yeah it's a database
it's the one that we use um on XYZ
project and you go okay cool I've used a
lot of postgress and I've read a lot
about SQL and nosql databases I'd love
to work with more different kinds of
databases so far it's mostly been
postgress and my SQL and frankly both of
those felt very similar to me I know
they both use a very similar dialect of
SQL for example but like you want to be
upfront about the fact that you haven't
used the thing yet because that's not
going to kill you in the interview for
the most part um but then try to tie it
back into something you do know right so
when someone says have you used mongodb
your answer probably shouldn't just be
no I haven't that's not only
unimpressive it's also a little awkward
like what's the followup uh for for that
conversation so you what you want to do
is say oh I haven't used that or oh I
don't know but and tie it into something
that you have done one more thing I'd
like to mention is you really should be
confident in
like you should be confident in your
passion for
coding right you should be really
confident about the fact that you love
to write code and that you learn you
love to learn new things um but you
should be really humble about the
process right so for example agile
versus
scrum test test driven development
versus literally anything
else right like you're Pro you've
probably been exposed over the course of
your Learning Journey to a lot of these
buzzwords a lot of these processes that
are used in the industry to actually
ship software right things like agile
scrum combon test driven development
domain driven development right clean
code like you'll have heard all of these
things um some of them are more
controversial than others but what I
would say is when this kind of stuff
comes up you want to mention you've
heard of it if you have but you don't
want to take a hard stance on it right
you really want to be humble about the
fact that you haven't used test driven
development in production yet maybe you
think it's interesting right maybe
you've done it on your own projects but
you're open to the you're you're really
open to the idea of learning from the
team and kind
of adapting to their processes because
at the end of the day that's really what
they want when someone hires an
entry-level developer they're not
looking for hard opinions on how to
improve their processes they're looking
on someone that they can train to do the
things the way that they're already
doing them when they hire a senior
developer they're much more interested
in that like industry experience right
and they might want to have their quote
unquote processes fixed right but but
when you're new they're probably hiring
you because they want to train you to do
things their way let's talk a little bit
about the actual interview process and
right up front I want to be very clear
this process will change from company to
company every company has their own
process right and it's something that
you should be extremely comfortable just
asking about upfront right when you get
on the phone when you get on that very
first phone screen with whoever it is
whether it's a recruiter or HR or even
the hiring manager themselves um just
ask like you know what does the
interview process look like what should
I expect what should I prepare for right
um but it usually looks something like
the these five steps so you've got a
phone screen that happens after someone
has reviewed your application found it
interesting they just call you up right
they want to hear your voice on the
phone they want to hear that you're a
real person they might ask you a few
kind of follow-up questions just to
verify different things that youve
listed on your resume make sure that
they're legit but the phone screen is
not an interview so like really really
really don't be stressed like do not be
stressed on the phone screen they're
just trying to kind of see that you're
real so that they can get the rest of
the process started the next one might
be a homework assignment um not all
companies do homework assignments um I
have found it tends to be a little more
common with entry-level positions than
not but but really it's it's usually
just like a one or 2hour coding
challenge um that's they're really
trying to weed out like the low effort
appliers um with homework assignments um
you'll hear a lot of opinions out there
about homework assignments ments uh you
know whether you should take your the
time to do them it's kind of unfortunate
that like you're not paid to do this
2hour coding challenge
um my recommendation is just if you have
the time to do them do them right like
when you're an entry-level developer
like Beggars can't be choosers it's no
secret that the industry at the moment
is not great for entry-level developers
right and it gets much better once you
have some experience but like the great
thing about a homework assignment is if
you do it well drastically increases
your chances of doing well in the
interview but also it's it's a challenge
like it is coding practice it's
something that you should be spending
your time doing anyways right learning
and improving so I don't really view
homework as you know something that
should be avoided at all costs although
of course you do need to limit the
amount of time you're spending on these
things if you've got 10 homework
assignments to do that can be
unreasonable and you might have to turn
some down now next comes the actual
interviews um there's typically a
cultural interview and a technical
interview this could go in either order
it might just be one single interview it
might be multiple interviews as a rule
of thumb the larger the company the
longer the hiring process with more
interviews involved usually small
companies tend to move a lot faster um
but the cultural interview often times
is with somebody higher up than just
like the technical team lead um in my
experience um often times if it's a
smaller company you know think 25 to 50
employees it might just be the CEO thems
like just getting to know you and seeing
if they like you right because the CEO
might not be managing your technical
abilities directly so they are kind of
Outsourcing the vetting of your coding
abilities to you know say the team lead
or something um but they are very
interested in whether or not you'll be a
cultural fit and cultural fit is just
corporations speak for like are you fun
to work with are you hardworking are you
driven right um and so there's there's
usually not too much preparation to do
here um other than like be on your best
behavior and try to put your best
attitude forward now the technical
interview in fact let me scroll down to
to this section on the technical
interview um there's usually several
different types of technical interviews
um that you'll encounter um
whiteboarding problems are very common
that's where you essentially stand at a
whiteboard or if you're doing a virtual
interview you might be drawing on some
uh mirror board or sharing your screen
while typing in a in a text editor um
but usually you're given some sort of
programming challenge think like a a
almost like a elite code style challenge
and you're expected to kind of walk
through the pseudo code or sometimes
like the architecture of how you would
solve the problem right um um I
personally this is an unpopular opinion
I personally really like whiteboarding
because it lets me show off how I think
about problems without having to worry
about like nitty-gritty syntax or typing
while someone's looking which is really
hard for me I do I do really poorly in
live coding um some people really like
live coding exercises um which are
typically take the form of like Elite
code or a hacker rank style challenge
where you sit there and you actually
write the code out and you compile it
and you run it and you look at the
result results um again some people
really like that um it's kind of one of
the most raw ways to see like can
somebody solve a problem with code um
the reason I struggle with it is because
again I really am bad at typing Under
Pressure I have no problem like thinking
Under Pressure that's why I do pretty
well with with whiteboards but like
typing and fumbling around with my keys
while everybody's looking on me and
there's a ton of pressure I struggle
with um the reality is that um you don't
get to pick the what the interview
format will be at least I've never been
able to pick
um but that you you you shouldn't be
discouraged when you get an interview of
the type that you're not confident in
like just don't let it get you down for
example if if I did if I just did live
coding interviews let's say I did like
three and I just felt awful because I
was bombing them and gave up that would
be a huge tragedy because I've landed a
lot of jobs through whiteboarding
problems in interviews and through
architecture and design patterns
questions like I I do pretty well at
those relatively speaking and so if you
get some hard interviews ju just don't
let it get you down realize that every
company's going to have a different
process right and and you might be
better at some than than others and if
you interview enough you will get all
different
types architecture and design questions
these ones are fun these are like um say
you had to build a web app that did X
like what kind of Technologies would you
use where would you deploy it how do all
of the different deployments talk to
each other right is it over HTTP are you
sending Json requests what do the Json
what does the shape of the Json objects
look like right um I really enjoy those
um another one that I see a lot less of
but I wish I saw more of is walkthroughs
of past projects so one of the
interviews that I landed and got a job
from was an a technical interview where
it just BAS basically for the entire
hour the interviewer said hey you listed
this project on your resume let's pull
it up let's pull it up on GitHub talk me
through it like why did you do this this
way why did you choose this library
right how do you deploy it why did you
decide to make the command line flag
this instead of that right um that's a
really cool in my opinion that's a
really cool way to do an interview um
but anyways just realize there's a few
different types and this again just goes
to say like you will need to do a lot of
interviews because you're going to need
practice with each different type of
interview so expect to do you know five
to 10 interviews um before you're
getting you know an offer or two now
there's really a few different types of
companies that you can apply for and
they all will have very different
interview processes so for example if
you mostly apply to Fang companies so
Facebook Apple Amazon Google Netflix
these companies are famous for doing a
lot of live coding exercises leite code
style CH challenges algorithms questions
and so if you're primarily interested in
those companies those big sexy tech
companies you're going to have to spend
a lot of time like grinding Le code and
doing a ton of coding challenges to
practice and prepare for those
interviews but not all companies are
like that smaller companies they're not
just interested in bringing on people
that can solve hard algorithmic problems
they're more interested in bringing on
people that can solve their immediate
problems which in a startup is rarely
that they need some tricky algorithmic
thing solved right like they just need
someone that can ship to production and
do it consistently and hopefully with
few bugs right generally speaking they
they're looking more for generalists
than Specialists so just understand that
different companies approach things
different ways and I interviewed Melky a
friend of mine on the backend banter
podcast recently about this exact topic
where he talks about how he would
approach preparing for in particular
Fang companies uh with leite code
challenges so let's cut over to that and
actually before we cut to this clip I
just want to point out what Melky is
responding to was a question I asked him
about how would you
recreate your current job at twitch he's
an engineer at twitch um if you had to
start over again and he has some hot
takes about Elite code and about
projects so let's take a
look
essentially the first step is buying 90
days what however you can do it if you
have to get a loan to get 90 days then
do that if you have to just work for I
don't know four months to buy 90 days I
would do that the goal number one is to
buy buy time however you can and then
the first thing I would do is lead code
I would lead code every single day when
I was when I got my job at twitch I was
lead coding 12 hours a day every single
day for uh I think it was like four
weeks I stopped streaming I I take this
seriously right like there's no
shortcuts so I was literally like Le
coding for 14 hours a day all I did wake
up Le code until I went to bed like my
eyes would i' would be in a basement no
sun didn't go outside didn't work out
yeah
pale yeah just pale skin like everything
like that man and like I would like
smoke jewels to like make sure like I'm
I'm like active my brains functioning um
but yeah I'd buy 90 i' some get 90 days
and then I would lead code for at least
at least eight hours a day of Le code so
I'd wake
up yes easy easy I'd wake up and I put
eight hours every like seven days
there's no days off I would take maybe
Sunday days off only Sunday would be the
day that you can actually relax um so
eight hours a day like that would be 9
to5 and then I would give myself two or
three hours so let's say that brings us
to like eight or nine and then I would
do projects I'll would build projects
using the L technology so if I want to
be frontend Dev I'm spinning up T3 stack
and I'm figuring out what's going on
here I'm watching Theo I'm watching
Prime I'm doing whatever I can I'm
watching YouTubers
build projects I'm mimicking it right I
go watch traversy media he's doing a
course on M Stack I'm learning M Stack
and that'll be my evenings that'll be
like from like 9 to midnight or 8 to
midnight that might have felt
intimidating uh Melky goes uh goes
pretty hard in the paint to say the
least I don't think
that in order to get your first job you
need to grind this hard I certainly did
not grind this hard for 90 days um but
the point that Mel is making is a very
good one and it's just to point out look
this is not like this is not easy
there's a lot of competition for these
jobs especially at the Fang jobs like
the twitch and the Netflix which of
course is where Melky works so if you're
going to go for a lot of those more
highly competitive remote um High
salaried right those jobs are going to
be more competitive and you are going to
have to grind and get really really good
so Le coding for eight hours a day is
probably going to be useful um one thing
that he goes on to say that I didn't
include in the clip is just that at
larger companies the lead code things
really important at smaller companies
the projects tend to be more important
so as you're thinking about how you're
going to divide your time um and how
you're practicing and preparing for
interviews I would recommend if you're
mostly applying for like local jobs or
small to medium-sized companies that
spending time building projects and
deploying them and and kind of solving
real world uh tasks is going to be more
useful but if you're if you're going to
the big companies then grinding leak
code can certainly be helpful I also
just want to give my take on melky's
point about buying 90 days um that is a
strategy uh I think it depends on your
personality and so it really is just up
to you I wouldn't be so prescriptive as
to say you should quit whatever you're
doing and find eight hours a day to just
grind leak code and build projects um
not because I don't think that can work
like I think it can work especially you
know in melky's case it obviously did
work for him I tend to be a very
low-risk person uh and so you know when
I was applying for my jobs I had a job
at a bank and I was coding in the
evenings and on the weekends for you
know maybe two or three hours every
night and that worked for me so find
what works for you would be my advice
and it's great to hear different
perspectives right you shouldn't just
listen to me you shouldn't just listen
to Melky but it's it's good to listen to
all of us and kind of synthesize it and
and and figure out what's going to work
for you now let's talk about one of my
favorite tactics for when you're
actually in the technical interview
right obviously you just need to be
prepared you need to be a good developer
but there are a few tactics that I think
um uh you can work into your process
that'll take you at least give you a
little bit of an edge um and one of them
is that when you're doing the technical
interview try to make it feel like
you're already on the team this should
feel less like a confrontation or an
exam right where the interviewers are
like the professor in college and you're
like the student you want it to feel
much less like that and much more like a
collaboration where you're a junior Dev
and they're a senior developer trying to
help you through a problem the more you
can make it feel like a collaboration
not only will you actually get more help
and more hints uh from your interviewers
but it gives them more of a sense of
what it's going to be like working with
you and you want that feeling to be a
good one right you you want to show that
you are a good
collaborator okay so let's give some
examples so a bad example of this would
be the interviewer saying write a
function that takes in a string and
Returns the string in reverse order and
you just saying okay and then attempting
to write the whole function from scratch
and saying here you go that's not great
um if you happen to nail it and and get
the function perfect then that can go
okay but a better example and something
that will go go better even if you don't
quite get the function exactly perfect
is to let's just run through the
scenario again says write a function
that takes in a string and returns a
string reversed you say instead of just
okay you say got it how concerned about
memory are we should I try to reverse
the string in place or should I try to
create a new string right so rather than
just just making an assumption we're
going to ask about some of the
constraints of the problem right like
this string could be an entire novel
right could be like the whole uh
Frankenstein textbook or the whole I
guess Frankenstein novel written by Mary
shell right hundreds of pages of text
shoved into one string in which case our
solution might look a little bit
different right because we have we have
different things we're trying to
optimize for so even if you're confident
that you think you know what the
interviewer is looking for just the fact
that you're asking follow-up questions
actually shows a lot of good things
about your problem solving process so
I'd highly recommend asking follow-up
questions um really good for
collaboration the interviewer then says
okay let's say we're not concerned about
memory we just want a solution that
works that's great that like makes this
the problem less unknown and actually
makes it a little simpler right we can
just like forget about keeping you know
performance optimized which is great
because you might have sat there and
struggled with trying to come up with
the most performant way to reverse a
string when really all you need to do
was get something
working so um moving on uh after they
give you that that little hint you say
uh you go ahead and write the signature
of the function so this would just be
like in Python it would be like def
reverse and then like s is the input and
like that's it just just the signature
um and you might ask a follow-up
question we just want a single string in
single string out right and what this
means is you're just writing a part of
the function and you're making sure that
you're on the right track because the
last thing you want to do is get like 10
minutes into solving this thing only for
the interviewer to be sitting there
puzzled like what are they doing like
that that's not at all what I asked for
so what you kind of want to be doing is
prompting for feedback as much as you
can as you work through the problem it's
not just good for you because you'll get
more hints it's good for the interviewer
because it shows them how you think
through this stuff right um which is
actually more impressive rather than
less so we just want single string in
single string out right interviewer says
yep um and then while writing the rest
of the function you might say okay so
I'll just create a new string Loop
through the input string backwards and
add each character to the new string
this should handle cases of FD strings
automatically the point here being
rather than just like silently writing
the code you can break the awkward
silence by in English kind of just
explaining what you're doing and again
there's a few advantages to this um the
first is if the interviewer hears that
your thought process is like way off
they'll probably try to steer you in the
right direction before you've even
written the whole code but if you just
sit there and write it in silence you
might sit there for five minutes like
struggling to put something together
that makes sense only then for the
interviewer to be like oh actually that
that code doesn't quite look right like
maybe try this other thing so if you if
you kind of say what you're thinking up
front it it improves the feedback loop
and you'll just get those suggestions
earlier and you'll have a better overall
result so some of the key differences
are we want to ask a lot of clarifying
questions which means we're less likely
to write any incorrect code which is
obviously great um we're communicating
our thought process which means the
interviewer can help us when we get
stuck which is great means the
interviewer gets to see what we think
which again it it provides more signal
the whole point of this whole process is
the interviewer just wants to know are
we qualified and by us audibly you know
announcing our thought process it tells
them more about whether or not we're
qualified so that's good um it shows
that you think through edge cases
something you'll need to do on the job
right so um a lot of times you can just
say an edge case and the interviewer
will tell you whether or not you
actually need to write the code for it
often times just saying the edge case is
is enough signal to the employer like
hey this person thinks through edge
cases we don't actually have to you know
write all of that extra code but now I'm
I'm glad to know that you thought of it
um it also shows you're a great
communicator which is like super
critical to being a developer I think
this is often overlooked we think it's
just about you know heads down being a
Code Monkey but actually so much of what
we do as developers is communicating
with the other developers on the team
it's communicating with stakeholders
with project managers with designers um
and so just showing that you're you're
good at that whole process is uh
extremely
valuable the last thing I'll say is you
want to use words like we and US instead
of you and me right so do we want this
function to take a string and return a
string is a lot better than do you want
me to write a function that takes a
string and returns a string and it's
it's actually just a really simple
reason it's it feels a little more
helpful and friendly
right it's a little it's a little warmer
of an interaction it also kind of
implicitly assumes that you're already
on the same team which is I don't know
if that's I don't think I don't think
that's sleazy but it's like this you
know this like little implication like
I'd love to be on the team um but it
actually goes a long ways in just in
terms of making the whole uh process
feel a lot more collaborative so
something that goes along with being on
the team is just asking a lot of
questions and when you're in school
taking an exam usually questions are not
allowed right the professor doesn't
allow you to just raise your hand and
ask for the question to answer five um
or even to ask for help on question
number five in an interview it's
different yes you can't usually just
straight up ask for the answer but you
almost certainly can ask for help and
you can certainly ask for
clarification um and it's really
important to just understand that asking
questions makes you look smart it
doesn't make you look dumb right not
asking any questions frankly makes you
look a little incompetent because on the
job when you're handed requirements from
product like build this feature it is
rare that the requirements are in such
pristine clear condition that you can
just go code it without asking any
follow-up questions right so you want to
show that you're thinking about the
problems and that you're thinking about
edge cases and in order to deal with
that you have to ask a lot of clarifica
uh clarifying questions so uh smart
people ask a lot of questions they're
knowledge sponges right smart people
want to learn as much as they can and
generally speaking people want to work
with other smart people so the first
tactic I want to mention here is that
you want to turn any question that you
would respond to an I don't know with
into a conversation so when you're
presented with a question that you don't
know the answer to the absolute worst
thing you can do is try to fake it it's
the worst thing you can do because if
you're
wrong and it's obvious that you're
faking
it a lot of trust is lost right the
interviewer kind of assumes that you're
you're lying a little bit or you're
exaggerating your abilities the last
thing you want to do is to say that it's
X confidently when it's really not so
when you do know something say it
confidently right um when you don't know
something it's really good to own up to
the fact that you don't know it but
there's a good way to do that if you
just say I don't know there will be an
awkward PA right and we want to avoid
awkward pauses in the conversation so
hey Lane have you ever worked with
postgress or I guess that's not the
right question let's try again
um hey Lane how does postgress index
rows on
dis I don't know right that's that's not
the right way to answer we want to we
want to give them a little bit more than
that so let's take a look at an example
uh bad example so the interviewer says
what is a closure and when would you use
one and you say I think it has to do
with functional programming but I don't
know so that's that's not a great
answer although it is a little better
than just a I don't know that's kind of
the worst case scenario so better
example what is a closure when we would
use one you respond with I learned about
closures when I took a course on
functional programming but I don't
remember all the details I do remember
using them in my link aggregator project
did have something to do with functions
and state right so functions and state
is actually pretty vague
right everything that functional
programming aims to address has to do
with functions and state so even if all
you can remember is that sometime in the
past you heard about
closures in your functioning functional
programming course the better that you
can do uh or the best that you can do to
take a stab at a guess or try to related
it to a project you built um that's
going to go a long way in like giving
the interviewer a way to follow up and
provide explanation a lot of times
they'll just straight up explain to you
what a closure is and you can be like oh
that's interesting that sounds useful in
XYZ case right so like once it's been
explained to you now you can understand
why that would be useful and you can
tell them why you think it would be
useful which does show you know a deeper
understanding that you have of
programming and then of course
clarification question so let's take a
look at another example so the
interviewer says let's say you're
designing a crud API to manage users and
their photos how would you design the
endpoints so you take a few seconds of a
pause and and and that's that's another
Point that's that's useful like don't be
scared of a little bit of Silence in
your interviews take a second think
about stuff um and you just ask a
followup question hm are users allowed
to share the photos right because that
actually informs quite a bit um how you
would design like the data model model
right whether a user has their photos or
whether multiple users can have access
to those same photos so the interview of
course says good question let's assume
that users can share the photo the the
photos but there's one primary owner of
each photo right just the fact that you
ask this question is a win for you like
you already look a little bit better in
the interviewer's eyes Okay and then you
can give you can give a specific answer
like okay well then I should probably
have a slash users endpoint to get
information about specific users and I
would have a SL users idos endpoint to
get all of the photos associated with
each user would that work for our use
case right and then of course rather
than just asserting the answer you can
say would that work it's just like a
softer Landing for your answer that I
found helps a little bit let's talk
about preparing for each individual
interview so we talked about how if you
apply to 100 jobs you might land land
just a handful of interviews and what
that means is when you do get an
interview you should take it fairly
seriously because in order to get
another one you know you're probably
have to apply to 20 or 30 places so um
when you do get an interview um you want
to kind of treat it with the respect it
deserves that doesn't mean again that
like the pressure is on and that you
shouldn't relax you you definitely
should um in the interview you should
should kind of relax and try not to take
it too seriously but before the
interview you should take it very
seriously and try to do some preparation
because just even just a little
preparation even just like an hour or
two before the interview can have
massive impact on your ability to land
the job so a couple of the things that I
talk
about um are that the first things
you're going to want to do is a little
bit of research on the company when you
show up to the interview you want to
know what the company does right what
they sell right do they sell a software
product do they sell programming
services like how do they make make
their money what's the thing that the
team does just high level this only
takes like 15 minutes right you go to
their homepage you read their about page
um this isn't a big deal but it means a
lot going into the company that you
already know what they do it shows that
you actually care about this
position um the next thing is you're
going to want to know um you're going to
want to know the names of all of the
programming languages and Frameworks and
tools that are listed in the job
description so this is this is really
simple idea the job description probably
has like 15 Technologies listed right we
use JavaScript we use typescript we use
view we use whatever you don't
have to master all of those but you have
to know what they are or you should know
what they are because it just takes half
an hour of research to figure out what
each one is on that note I'm going to
cut to the primagen who I had on my
podcast um and actually this clip is not
from the podcast he was on my podcast
but this is unrelated um but this clip
is where he talks about this preparation
process and what he thinks you should be
doing to maximize your chances in the
interview if I were or were not to get
it the reason being is that interviewing
is a skill in of itself and it takes
practice so I would actually interview
for practice if I get a bunch of jobs
awesome I can use those to negotiate
with each other Mah beautiful and if I
get none of them I'm not heartbroken I
take the feedback I figure out what I
wasn't good at how I didn't communicate
well and where the mismatch happened
with the employer and improve on those
things second I would always be very
careful about the jobs you're applying
for and look at all the requirements
they want when you see all all of those
use it as a cheat sheet to at least be
able to intelligently speak about those
now you don't have to master those often
those things are just wish lists they're
not requirements and so that would kind
of be how I would approach getting a job
now I love rust I think it's way way
more fun to program than typescript but
the reality is that if I were starting
over I would start where you get hired
first and then the moment you get hired
use that use that money use that income
as just a way to be able to be stable
and learn then what you want to learn if
you feel really passionate about
compilers it's really hard to get a job
doing compilers but you could get a job
that will supplement you while you study
study study make blog posts do all those
things so you can move into that
position it's all about the long game
and really it's all about making
yourself better and here's the fun part
is you're going to take a job you think
I won't really like it you might find
you actually like something completely
different than you thought I'm 36 years
old and I still keep discovering things
I didn't realize I liked to do just one
more thing I want to add on top of what
prime said there was that when I say
surface level research on all of the
stuff in it in in a a job posting I
really mean surface level like when you
see postgress listed there just knowing
that it is a SQL database like that's
basically all you need to know and if
you don't know what SQL is like oh it's
a domain specific programming language
for uh querying data out of a database
right like just very very surface level
things um to get you to to get to get
you to a point where when someone
mentions that term so when someone says
postgress in the interview you don't
have a complete deer in the headlights
look that's all we're looking for really
now if you do have some extra time like
let's say you've got five days until the
interview you've got no other interviews
lined up I think it can be worth your
time to build little projects with some
of the technologies that seem more
important to the interview and that
actually can look really good in the
interview so let's say for example that
a company uses rabid mq for their
backend like asynchronous Pub sub
Communications so you saw that on the
job posting you've built a lot of
backend Services um in different
projects as you've been learning you've
never used rabid mq before so you do
your little surface level research you
figure out what Rabbid mq is and you
just spin up locally you spin it up
locally you build a few little command
line tools or a little web app that uses
it now when you walk into the interview
not only do you know what it is but you
can say oh yeah it was really
interesting to me when I was looking at
this job uh at the job posting I didn't
know what it was actually spun it up
built a little project with it um now
you can fairly confidently say that you
have experience with rabbit but it also
just shows that you have a lot of kind
of go get it attitude right like that
you were willing um an interested in
using one of these technologies that
you'd never used before just to prepare
for an interview right it shows a lot of
good soft qualities welcome to the final
chapter of this course it's time to talk
about relocation so relocation is a
funny subject um the world's changed a
lot in the last five years when I
started getting into programming a
decade ago I was under no impression
that it was even possible for me to get
a remote job and that's that's that's
only 10 years ago right um today it
seems like everyone that's learning to
code is under the impression that their
entire career they'll be working from
their own house now that can certainly
happen most jobs at tech companies can
be done remotely and there certainly are
a ton of remote companies and in 2020
and 2021 where practically every tech
company went fully remote um it was
obviously possible um a lot of companies
have gone back to on-site or hybrid and
a lot of new companies now in 2023 or
going into 2024 are moving back to the
office so um it's I I don't think we're
going back to nearly as on site as the
world was a decade ago but we're also
not as remote as the world was in 2020
and 2021 and here's my hot take I think
if you're looking for an entry-level
position your best bet is to go on site
and that's really for two reasons the
first is that I believe for most entry
level developers you will learn more and
improve faster in your you know first
couple of years at that company if
you're on site so that's number one it's
just better for your long-term career I
also think that it is generally easier
to find an onsite in-person job than it
is to find a remote job again as an
entry-level developer this all changes
once you're a senior right and this all
is kind of the waters are muddied by
influencers uh like myself right we all
work from home it seems um but that's
not really reflective of the industry
and especially not the entry level
industry so first let's dive into
exactly why it's easier to get a job on
site let's start with a circle this is
the world sometimes it's tempting to
think well let me let me let me start
with some we'll do some continents here
this will be the Americas and then over
here we'll
draw like Europe Europe maybe Africa
we'll assume that Asia's on the other
side of the planet this is like really
really beautiful
diagramming okay
cool here's the
world the assumption that a lot of
entrylevel developers make or new
developers especially after learning
that programming can be done
remotely is the assumption that it's
going to be easier to get a remote job
because you can apply to jobs across all
of these continents right across the
whole world right so for example let's
say that in the
world there may be I don't know let's
just pick a number 100,000
jobs that you can qualify for with your
skill set so for example if you're
looking for backend development jobs in
go let's just say there's 100,000 jobs
in the world um wow that's not How We Do
100,000 there we go
okay where you
live let's say that you live I don't
know
here let's say that where you
live your
city there's only I don't know 200
jobs right much fewer
so a lot of people will look at that
statistic and say okay I should focus on
remote jobs because there's 100,000
openings for remote jobs even though
there and and there's only 200 jobs in
my city right so just simple math I
should be applying for remote positions
here's why this is tricky and why you
shouldn't think about it this way what
that also means is that in the world or
or or I should say for each of those
100,000 jobs that's open to everyone in
the
world might be a million candidates
candidates right which means that those
jobs have many applicants maybe each job
is getting a thousand applicants right
anytime a company opens up a remote
position these days it's just flooded
with applications right okay so say a
million candidates um and then in your
city the interesting thing
is that in my experience the ratio is
actually better so maybe in your
city there's only 200
candidates now again I'm just making up
numbers here but the idea that I want to
demonstrate is that in my experience the
number of people applying to any
individual local job so a job in your
city that is not open to remote
work is going to have a lower Ratio or
lower number of candidates applying for
that individual job right so if I open a
local job here in American Fork
Utah I get 20 candidates right if I open
it to the world make it remote put it up
on LinkedIn I get a thousand candidates
right
so hopefully this this this make this
math is making sense right 100,000 total
jobs in the world 1 million candidates
200 jobs in your city 200 candidates the
idea is that you actually will have
better luck with the 200 jobs in your
city right it doesn't help you if there
are 100,000 total jobs to apply for
because in no world are you going to
have enough time to actually apply to
all 100,000 of those jobs now if you
happen to live in a city where there's
very few programming jobs it is like
possible that you apply to every job in
your city you get rejected and now it's
time for you to look remote I just want
to point out that
if you are physically able to work in
the office in your city I would start
there because I think you're actually
going to have better luck the odds are
more in your favor so let's take a few
notes the first
is we talked about this but if you can
work in an office that's what I'd
recommend so prefer working in office
for your first job I think it's going to
make it easier to land the job and I
think you'll learn more while you're
there which is great when you're when
you're just starting out once you have a
little more experience I think it's
fantastic if you go remote like no
problem at all um and then I do just
want to caveat if there if you have
something in your life that makes
working in office extremely difficult
for you right if you have a kid at home
for example um or if you have some sort
of health issue that makes it like
really tough I'm not saying that this is
the only way right uh I'm just saying if
it's an option that's available to you I
think it can make it easier for you okay
um the next point I want to make is that
well what should I do make this a
question what what should I
do if there are
no jobs near
me right uh you live in some like Podunk
Town not in San Francisco not in New
York right like what are your options so
I have have a little bit of insight here
I grew up in a town called St George
Utah um it's in southern Utah it's about
an hour and a half outside of Las Vegas
um it is not known for technology
companies uh especially when I was there
a decade ago um there was really like a
handful like two or three companies that
did software development that I was
aware of while I was living there uh and
that was it like that was it if you
didn't work at one of those three
companies congratul
like you're not working in
Tech um but little botes to me until I
actually did a bunch of research there
were some other opportunities at non-te
companies right so these these three
companies that like hired programmers
like one of them made a mobile app right
so obviously hiring developers one of
them did uh a bunch of custom
development with WordPress so they they
take a WordPress site and they' R write
a bunch of like custom PHP and they
build by the hour to do it um another
one of the software companies that's
much larger now um but it was a SAS
company they uh basically wrote
cloud-based software that manages
printers in offices um it was smaller
than it's much larger now there's really
only these few options uh I did some
digging I did some leg work uh and I
found a job listing I can't even
remember where I know it wasn't on
LinkedIn it might have been on like
indeed or honestly even Craigslist uh
which is pretty sketchy but that might
have been where I found it um for a
programming position in fact a part-time
programming position at a hardware
company they worked on they put sensors
on Bridges right um they had this little
product where they' throw up sensors on
Bridges they'd collect data and their
whole thing was like it was risk
mitigation right they were trying to
figure out um if there were any problems
with the bridges and they didn't even
have a software product at the time they
just really needed someone that could
like write scripts and Wrangle data
right run stuff against their SQL
database figure out what's going on with
the data parse it into Json hand it to
the electrical engineer just like little
odd jobs that you kind of need to be a
developer in order to be able to do
efficiently my point being like are you
sure are you sure there's no jobs uh
near you even if they're weird um I work
to that company for a little over a
year and like by industry standards I
was not paid well um I think at the time
I was making like $15 an hour uh I was
just finishing my CS degree but it was
one of the best things that I could have
done right because directly after that
with one year of experience under my
belt I went and worked at a sexy SAS
company making a lot more money as a
backend developer um so like all I would
say is are you sure are you sure there's
no like weird jobs at non sexy tech
companies in your local area where you
can get some programming experience
under your belt while you're still in
your kind of entrylevel Junior phase
okay so once you've looked in your local
area you feel like you've really spent
some time and you're convinced that
there just is not opportunity here you
basically have two options right you can
either you can either go remote oops you
can go remote or or you can look to
relocate so going remote in my mind is
like your last resort um if there's no
other options then go remote um it is
certainly possible to get remote work I
don't want to like I don't want anyone
to claim that I'm saying that it's
impossible to find remote work as an
entry level developer you can um I'm
just saying it's it's kind of hard mode
um so I'd save that for last uh what I
would do next is look into reloca
and uh if that like works for you so let
me clear off the board and there's
really two ways to think about
relocating so let's let's just talk
about relocation for a
second the two ways to handle relocation
are one
relocate then search for
jobs the other one obviously is to
search for jobs remotely
the
open to
relocation now of these two options
obviously option two is less risk right
and so with with with everything I say
in this chapter I'm really just trying
to help you understand some of the pros
and the cons of different decisions you
can make I don't want to prescribe what
you should do in your life um so with
that in mind option number two is going
to be lower risk
right it's really easy to look for jobs
remotely you can go to indeed or
LinkedIn or whatever and you can search
by jobs in San Francisco even if you
don't live in San Francisco and you can
apply to those jobs right and when you
talk to the recruiter or the hiring
manager you can just say oh I'm not in
San Francisco right now but like I'm
excited about moving as soon as I get an
offer in hand right and you could do
this you could do this right now there's
nothing stopping you
um I will
say it's a little
harder um that's the price you pay for
being risk averse just in the sense that
as a hiring manager if you have two
candidates that are roughly um you're
kind of equally excited about both of
them and one of them lives in town
already and you can just go meet them
for
coffee and you know if you hire them and
then fire them two months later or for
whatever reason because it didn't work
out like they didn't have to relocate
and go into a bunch of debt or whatever
it's just easier for the hiring manager
to work with someone that's already
local um as opposed to you
know they can't meet you for coffee uh
if you live halfway across the country
or halfway across the world um and
obviously like H1B visas and everything
come into play I'm not even going to
speak to that because I I know nothing
about how that works because I've always
worked in the US lived in the US um if
you want uh you know advice about that
you'll probably have to go to someone
else
but just understand that if you take
option two it is it is it is definitely
lower risk but uh the price of that is
it's going to be a little harder than if
you were actually in the
city okay so option one of course is to
just move if you're not in a great place
for jobs just go somewhere where the job
market is better and then look for work
right and of course that will make it
easier um you have to figure out what
works for you in your life um my gut
tells me well let let me just give you
my experience because again I don't want
to prescribe advice here um when I
graduated college I was married but with
no kids and my wife was an x-ray
technician so we could really live
anywhere so it wasn't a problem so like
I could just move from St George up to
Salt Lake which is what did and apply
for jobs there um there's a lot more
jobs in Salt Lake like like a lot more
um and it was fairly low risk the cost
of living in Salt Lake versus St George
is like marginally higher um and we were
just renting so like it really just
wasn't that hard to it wasn't it just
wasn't that hard to pick up our lives
and move my wife was able to find a job
up here in Salt Lake quite easily as an
X-ray tech contrast that with someone
right or or rather contrast that with me
right now in my life where I'm married
with two children and we own a home like
relocating would be a huge deal for me
right now um so to be honest if I was
learning to code right now where I'm at
in my life I would probably take option
two even though I'm probably going to
have to do more interviews it's going to
be more leg work before I get an
interview um the risk of moving and not
finding a job um
moving to a new city with no salary
shopping for a new house like it's just
not worth it to me right now so if you
are single right if you have the funds
then option one might be the better
option um but if you have a lot of
things tying you down to a location then
obviously uh you know number two could
be what you're looking for but I want to
point out that if you're even open to
the idea of
relocation option number two is going to
be a lot easier than let's go back to
talking about
remote option number three which is to
only
apply only apply to fully remote
positions right I would really only do
option number three if I had some reason
in my life something in my life that was
making it so that remote was
realistically the only only possibility
for me the very last thing I want to
leave with you with in this course is go
back to the very beginning where I drew
this graph right I drew this graph and I
said
along along the x- axis on the bottom
we've got
time and along the Y AIS we've got kind
of
likelihood doing weird things with my
arrow likelihood of getting a job
right and as time goes on you really
want to have a graph that looks like
this instead of a graph like so many
students
have that kind of looks like this as
they're learning and then actually
tapers off as they start their job
search or in the worst case actually
goes back down and I know at the
beginning of the course I was
emphasizing continuing to learn and
build and that is accurate you do want
to do that that can help kind of fix the
shape of this graph but there is one
other thing and that is to be be
extremely
extremely I'm not going to try to spell
extreme without spell check um be
very uh
critical and
reflective of your process
critical and reflective of your process
right so
um tying this into
relocation would
be I've seen a lot of students who
make quick assumptions kind of jump the
gun on what they think is the problem in
their job search right so they start
their job search um you know they're
looking for their first job in Tech not
an easy thing as we've gone over and
they assume oh I don't have you know I'm
not a graduate I don't have a boot camp
graduate uh like certificate I don't
have a CS degree that's definitely the
problem I'm going to go take out a bunch
of loans and go back to school or I'm
going to go do a Bo boot camp um I'm not
going to say those things can't help
they can uh but was that the problem if
you already are confident in your coding
abilities was that the problem are we
sure it wasn't that like your LinkedIn
and GitHub profiles are terrible are we
sure it's not not that like your
projects are really boring and nobody
cares about them right are we sure it's
not that you fail every whiteboarding
test or whiteboarding uh interview that
you've ever done like you kind of want
to be sure of those things before you do
a really high-risk thing right so um
going back to school in your 30s or
doing expensive boot camp in your 30s
like those things are fairly high risk
again not that they can't work but if it
were me I would want to be sure that
that's the thing I like back before I
take one of those larger risks and
relocation falls into the same category
for me so if you're having a really hard
time in your local area finding work and
you believe that relocation is the
answer it could be I would just
encourage you to like check all the
other boxes right review the other
chapters in the course is your LinkedIn
great is your GitHub great are your
projects awesome right is it really is
it really just a location and if it is
then then look into solving your problem
that way um but if it's not maybe fix
the lower hanging fruit first now I just
want to reiterate that this is not a
course on math right the things that
I've shared in this course have
primarily just been anecdotes and
stories and things that I believe will
help you in your job search there is no
correct answer for what's the best way
to get a programming job right all there
are are opinions and stories and
experiences from people who have done it
and that's what I'm trying to synthesize
and share with you here I hope you found
this valuable try your best to adjust
all the things that we've talked about
in this course to your life and apply
them to your situation because your
situation is um different than mine um
again if you want the text version of
this course it is fully free on boot.
paid memberships on bootd are only
required for all of the interactive
features like the gamification the
progress tracking if you just want to
read and watch all of the content that
is fully free so you can go check that
out um best of luck on your job search